e
ch
chair we'll call on senator birdsville
who is the Prime
sponsor of Senate Bill
366 good morning Senator good morning
how are you I'm just
dandy
well um for the record my name is Regina
burzell state senator for district 19
which is encompasses the towns of Derry
Hamstead and Windham and I want to thank
the chair and the committee for hearing
um Senate Bill
366 um this is a pretty
bipartisan um piece of legislation it
passed the Senate 24 to nothing on a
Voice vote um so to start out um since I
heard about the Chinese company fuang
purchasing agricultural land in North
Dakota near Grand Forks Air Force Base I
have been concerned about the potential
land grab from the CCP which which is
why I chose to bring this bill
forward this legislation is similar to a
bill introduced in Florida in which the
r a penned an amicus brief in support of
their
legislation this bill bans the CCP from
purchasing any land near a military base
New Hampshire National Guard facility or
any major infrastructure in the
state in 20201 a Chinese company called
fuang group based in chandong China
bought a plot of land in North Dakota as
a site for a manufacturing facility a
proposed project that would be based
within 20 minutes of Grand Forks Air
Force Base which houses our nation's
most sensitive military drone technology
and the backbone of our military
Communications across the
globe while the Air Force has not
outwardly opposed this purchase a major
at the base circulated his concerns
about the project which was brought uh
which brought broad bipartisan concern
including a statement from the US China
economic and Security review stating the
location of the land close to the base
is particularly convenient from
monitoring air traff air traffic Flows
In and Out of the base among other
security related
concerns while the company is not a
state-owned Enterprise its chairman
previously participated in a provincial
people's Congress provincial legislature
of the People's Republic of
China we must understand that in 2017
the CCP passed
legislation uh the National Intelligence
law which allows the Chinese Communist
party to order citizens or comp or a
company to assist in any intelligent
work Chinese citizens and organizations
are beholding to China China's citizens
cannot truly own property all land is
legally owned by the state which means
it's owned ultimately by the
CCP since at least 2017 Federal
authorities have investigated Chinese
land purchases near critical
infrastructure shut down a high-profile
Regional consulate believed by US
government to be a hotbed of Chinese
spies and um and Stonewall what they saw
as clear effort to plant listening
devices near sensitive military and
government
facilities at the end of 2010 according
to USDA foreign Holdings of us
agricultural land reports China had
invested 13, ,700 in 13,720 acres of um
us land all told at the end of 2020 um
China had a total of
352,000
um acres of land that they had
purchased currently Hawaii Iowa
Minnesota M Mississippi North Dakota and
Oklahoma already banned foreign
ownership of farmland and legislation
has been introduced in Texas to prevent
malicious use of infrastru
structure it is understood that China
can circumvent restrictions on land
ownership by buying large US
corporations that own agricultural land
or purchase interest in overseas
corporations that do business in the
USA additionally Chinese investors
investors owners and workers have
emerged in recent years as a new source
of funding and labor for illegal
marijuana Productions and I do have a
letter um that I can forward to the
committee from um
Jean
Shaheen uh jeene Shaheen signed off on
it Chris Papa signed off on it um to
Meritt Garland asking them to
investigate the land purchases in Maine
and I'll read a little bit of that as
well um Chinese investor owners owners
and workers have emerged in recent years
as a new source of funding and labor for
illegal marijuana Productions from
interviews with state law enforcement
officials expert on the international
drug trade economists and lawmakers the
number of farms funded by sources
traceable back to Chinese investors or
owners has skyrocketed Chinese owners
and workers have become a larger
Presence at illegal grows in Oklahoma
California and Oregon in Oklahoma close
to 3,000 of the states nearly 7,000
licensed marijuana Farms have been
flagged for suspicious activity by law
enforcement over the last year the
agency believes that 2,000 of those
Farms have a connection
Supply workers and funding or both law
enforc ment in southern Oregon in 2021
reported as many as 20 different
nationalities linked to Illegal grows
but the increasing amount of Chinese
funding and what lawmakers is some is
some expertise as a potential influence
of the Chinese Communist party has
caught their
attention Additionally the belt and Road
initi initiative is a massive Chinese Le
infrastructure project that aims to
stretch around the globe a 2021 study
analyzes over 100 debt financing
contracts China signed with foreign
governments and found the contracts
often contained Clauses that restrict
restructuring with the group of 22 Main
creditor Nations known as Paris Club
China also retains the right to demand
repayment any time giving Beijing the
ability to use funding as a tool to
enforce Chinese hot button issues such
as Taiwan or the treatment of yugar in
January 2022 Nicaragua officials joined
the BR one month after severing diplom
Diplomat diplomatic ties with
Taiwan and I know this puts us in a tie
spot and when we're the live for your
die state but we can and should not make
it easy for adversaries to come into our
state and work against us I'm sure
you'll hear testimony against this but
any amendments must be very tightly
worded because remember if one Chinese
National owns property the CCP owns the
property and there's um a letter dated
February 2nd and I can afford it to um
it's to Meritt Garland and it's signed
by a broad bipartisan group of uh US
senators and US Congress and in that is
Chinese Nationals including those with
potential ties to the Chinese Communist
Party are reportedly operating thousands
of illicit marijuana Farms across the
country a leaked Department of Homeland
Security document from August
2023 estimated Asian transnational
criminal organizations are link are
linked up to
749 of these sites just in Maine in
alone sophisticated Chinese Affiliated
marijuana operations have been
discovered in California Washington
Oregon Massachusetts Michigan and and
Nevada for example in Colorado a Chinese
cartel bought suburban homes near Denver
and grew thousands of marijuana plants
in residential basements whether located
in retrofitted residential homes or on
Farmland state regulatory and law
enforcement entities appear unable to
address these potential CCP supported
grow operations despite their
significant threat to local communities
communities
across the country in addition to
growing marijuana investigators in
Oklahoma discovered IL illicit marijuana
growers engaged in human trafficking sex
trafficking ketamine trafficking illegal
gambling and international moneya
laundering so I would you know in
closing I would say that we do have a
very vested interest and it's getting a
lot closer to home the states that have
um legalized marijuana have seen a
ballooning of these um illegal marijuana
facilities growing with that I'll take
any
questions okay d
represent
ton hi hi so before I ask my question I
want to establish that I am no supporter
of the red
Chinese however I am also a real estate
broker and I have to ask this question
in good
conscience with I understand all the
good reasons for wanting to pass this
bill I understand the threat to our way
of life keeping it really simple but
you're putting a restriction
on who I can sell my property to and who
can own property if this bill
passes and
so
uh that's my concern because today we
don't like the red Chinese fine what if
we don't like Jews tomorrow what if we
decide Catholics shouldn't be able
to own property and that is a real thing
that has happened in the history of this
country as you may well know Catholics
couldn't sit in this legislature until
the 20th century
so there's all kinds
of uh I'm concerned that this is a
slippery slope and I would hope that
there I I certainly hope that doesn't
happen but where's the protection that
we don't go down that road other than
our good judgment well first of all
Catholics and the Jews are protected um
under our constitution but if if you're
looking for authority to be able to sell
your land to the CCP that is close to a
military base then I would say no that's
stop China is one of our biggest
adversaries and they have been for a
long time and nothing's going to change
on that piece so I I I do say that if
you're willing to sell your land to a
Chinese organization that you know is
going to be run by the CCP and next to
one of our military bases or our
National Guard
um I say
no yeah but I let me just clear that
question up cuz I see this 10
miles but then I'm looking at this list
and there's there's
nowhere in the state of New Hampshire
where there isn't a restaurant a bank a
dam within 10 miles well so aren't you
really for all tens of purposes Banning
any purchase of any land
by the Chinese government we're
restricting any purchase of land within
10 miles as I said of a National Guard
military installation and some
infrastructure nothing's nothing is
there about restaurants well I I said
okay so food and agricultural
facilities including but not limited to
Farms
restaurants and food manufacturing so
just but I'm just going through this
list now not withstanding that I happen
to the only legislator that owns a dam
so I did that kind of stook out out in
me okay and I'm saying 10 miles from me
well 10 miles that's to that's town
every town around is when 10 so for all
sens of purposes I mean Bridges I mean
tell me a town that doesn't have a
bridge okay it is true we have no
tunnels it is true we have no tunnels I
don't believe there's a tunnel in nature
okay right that is true okay so for all
sense of purposes you are Banning
any purchase of any land in the state of
of anywhere in New Hampshire because
there's no place that is going to meet
this 10 Mile re is correct okay great so
spear I can certainly understand the
National Guard and the uh military B
it's not really a military base it's a
listening satellite listening station up
in uh I think it's in New Boston New
Boston is that where it is yeah yeah I
can understand you know that kind of
thing uh and I can even understand
preventing the sale of land right near
BAE Systems which is one of the most
secure facilities we have in the state
but we also have an agricultural
facility I don't know exactly where it
is because I don't know where anything
is uh that is the farmers have said have
come in in previous bills liked it they
says please whatever you do don't get
rid of that and the Chinese do own that
and it provides uh a very elaborate
uh I don't know collection of research
for the agricultural industry and it it
used to be owned by the Swiss I think
and now it's owned by the
Chinese but it's but the problem and and
I feel that we can't
really
uh I I don't know what to do with that
but what I guess my question is this
thank you are you EXP exp in if somebody
comes to me are you expecting me as an
individual or as a real estate person to
investigate these people's background
and figure out if they're Chinese and if
they don't I go to jail well you have to
on the transfers there's a form you have
to sign now for the Feds that says it's
not a uh you have to say whether it's an
out of state out of yeah but I don't
know that anything that they said was
real no I know that but there is a for
there is a federally mandated form on
every real EST estate transaction that
where you as the seller and
affirmatively state that to the best of
your knowledge this is not
a uh external entity but the point is I
don't know the person tells me something
I believe them I don't know your defense
he's saying that your defense is that
you had that you signed that form is
that a good enough defense for this any
person who fails to comply with this
section not that that's a sort of a
would you believe okay
Herbert um does China allow us to buy
land in their uh absolutely
am thank you senator for your taking our
questions um the bill I don't believe
addresses existing property that's owned
or potentially owned by an entity that
you know it there could be a long string
of shell companies that goes back to the
CCP um do do you intend uh to sever
ownership of land that could be
potentially traced back to the CCP
currently owned well I I this bill
wouldn't take effect until after after
that transaction so I would say no okay
but I think at the time if they decide
to sell it then that the new seller
could could not be a member of the CCP I
see thank
you and and this is only for sales not
for renting as far as I know yeah okay
so I again this was a this was a piece
of legislation that our attorney general
had
um they he he did an amicus brief on the
piece of legislation down in Florida so
he strongly they strongly support this
got it okay repres
representative burough yes sorry I keep
Wan calling you Anita sorry that's okay
thanks for taking my question I think
one question that um some people may
have is what can we do to protect
Chinese who may be here from other
countries um even US citizens from
discrimination in uh when they want to
buy this type of property how can we
protect them um and and and the Realtors
um who may be selling to them and how do
we do that well the one thing that if
there US citizens whether regardless of
what their nationality is they're US
citizens they're eligible to purchase um
but understand that if they are Chinese
nationalists or um uh Chinese company in
2017 the Chinese passed legislation that
would require anyone who's a Chinese
National they don't own the property the
CCP
does so we need to be very cognizant of
the fact that um if you're selling to a
Chinese nationalist you are virtually
selling to the
CCP because under Chinese law the
national the individual does not own
property nor does um the Chinese
company they are required to work under
the CCP guidelines further question
mqu thanks I what I was actually getting
at is let's just hypothetically somebody
a Chinese uh person comes over from
London you know how do we protect them
and maybe you
know how do we protect them against
discrimination for having them
associated with the CCP when they're not
if
they're now I know there are certain
individuals that come over like let's
say their their children are going to
school at Philips Academy and they they
either purchase or they rent property
that should not be an issue but if
you're going to be purchasing land
around any of those
facilities then it's going to be a
problem just like Maine's having the
problem with um Maine and what
California
729 Parcels of
land uh the CCP has
purchased um and they're growing illegal
marijuana but that doesn't I guess I I
still don't hear an answer to the
question which is a a citizen of Britain
comes over here and wants to buy
agricultural land say near New Boston
you know how number one how does the
realtor know that they're not you know
how do they investigate to find out that
they're not affiliated with the CCP or
that their rights are protected to be
able to have them buy land well if
they're a citizen of England then
they're not a member of the CCP okay
that's that's okay so I um can you just
read what you said before that if
somebody uh his student is at Philips
Andover and they're from the People's
Republic you said it wouldn't be a
problem for them to buy a house I would
think so well it's got to be 10 10 miles
of a
restaurant so they no they
can't okay and has also been pointed out
is that uh lease is in here so that
means as someone like me who does
vacation rentals I've got to figure out
whether the person who's renting the
yes you just lost my vote okay did I
ever have it
representative probably not thought but
you just helped me kill it my own mind
okay yes representative thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you senator for
bringing the bill and thanks for taking
my question um my question
is the United States has a number of
serious enemies of the state like
Russia should we also restrict transfer
of real property to those enemies of the
state like
Russia I would say not yet I mean there
are pieces of legislation out there that
ha have restricted um Iran
Russia um
China um and I think there
was no there's one other one um they
have restricted we are just looking at
the CCP because the CCP is really the
largest perpetrator in in our country on
purchasing land purchasing
businesses what follow up further
question may
inquire um when I read through some of
the details of the bill I I had not
noticed that it's quite Broad and it's a
full restriction because it does include
like
Bridges and and
restaurants would you be open to
amending it so it's a little more narrow
and restricts um transfer of real
property to areas around our most
critical installations like the actual
military bases and not just every bridge
and
McDonald's I I would and I would also be
willing to look at um if you wanted to
amend it to Pro protect individuals who
want to um lease or purchase um for the
purposes of residential but I would be
very uh careful when you do when you do
that
because I'm sorry ask the question again
so I diverted it's pretty it's pretty
Broad and while I while I think
the the principle of protecting our
country's most valuable and our state's
most valuable assets especially our
military and our our special secrets and
things that so many people don't even
know about in New Boston and whatnot
that's and our critical infrastructure
is important sebr nuclear those thing
those things but restricting the the
open Commerce that's so important to our
state like renting an
Airbnb a mile from a McDonald's which is
really what this would restrict that
might be a little broad I'd be happy to
work on narrowing the scope of this
legislation if you'd be open to it I am
okay um I would be very cognizant too of
the fact that um we're we're talking
about a the agricultural business as
well and the Chinese have infiltrated
that with their um um purchasing land
for seed po uh propagation and they're
um gaining more and more of our food
lines so I'd be very cognizant of that
as well thank you okay
uh good morning thank you for taking my
question do you know if other states
have enacted this legislation and how
they're dealing with researching you
know as uh representative Amon said you
know there could be several different
shell companies until you get to the
real owner so that just seems to be a a
complication of how to do that research
and what is the experience of other
states if they've passed something
similar thank you other states has have
as I stated in here
um uh
um Hawaii Iowa Minnesota Mississippi
North Dakota and Oklahoma they've
already banned it so what I can do is
try and contact some of the uh
representatives in that state and see
residents amm next and then represent
spe thank you again for taking our
questions and just to follow up on on
the previous question um has there been
any analysis
of currently owned property in the state
is there a way to figure out how big of
a problem this might be currently um
based on you know titles and deeds uh of
of existing property you mean in New
Hampshire in New Hampshire is is there
if there isn't you know is there a way
to figure out how big of an issue that
this is currently I can talk to um
attorney general Chris Assistant
Attorney General Chris Bond who helped
me write the legislation and see what he
know what he can find out it' be yeah
it'd be good just to get a handle on how
big of a problem it is currently thank
you representative
spear this this may be a would you
believe I I retired from BAE Systems in
2020 prior to
20120 and at the time of my leaving we
had personnel there with that were
Chinese Nationals holding green cards
and BAE Systems has some of the highest
secrets in the country they had no
problem they did their a security
investigations and did whatever they do
and they had no problem hiring these
people and these people bought homes
on what we're expecting here especially
in light of even ba systems didn't have
a problem would you believe would you
believe I would believe that because I
also worked at rathon over the past few
years though it's been becoming a um uh
problem in the security aspect of it now
Bae may very well be doing their their
due diligence in the background check
but as as we said I will look um look
through the other states that have
passed it try and talk to some of their
representatives and find out how they
protect if anyone's coming in to
[Music]
um purchase land or purchase a um house
so that they can see their kids graduate
I will look into that and see how they
protect them or rent it a vacation
rental okay vacation
rentals okay I wouldn't want my my my
son-in-law owns one so I wouldn't want
either represent rner thank you thanks
for taking my question um I guess I'm
concerned about enforcement because the
bill does not actually require a seller
or anybody who's renting property to do
any due diligence about the buyer or the
renter and there's no reference in there
to any government
agency doing research into these
purchases so how how would it be
enforced and that's a question I'll ask
Chris spon because I mean obviously he
had it when he they did the Amicus brief
in Florida they obviously had a process
that he was thinking of when they put
that Amicus brief together
okay thank you very much for your
testimony you're welcome I have one card
here uh Robert Johnson from the Farm
bill good morning good morning thank you
Mr chair and members of the committee
for the record my name is Rob Johnson
and I appeared before you representing
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau is a
federation's policy director and we do
oppose the the bill as drafted we
certainly share the concerns and support
the intent of the sponsor no doubt but
as you've pointed out the bill is
written is very absolute and it's broad
there's there's no ability for somebody
to plead their case as to why they don't
fall under this category and as as has
been pointed out in the bill language
itself it it does include in lines eight
and nine you know leasing possessing or
exercising control in addition to
ownership and it is as been pointed out
it's it's it's you know this critical
infrastructure as defined is very broad
uh you look on uh page page two line 18
where it says the word Farms well my my
Forest land is part of my farm I know
many people think it's just a crop land
but my Forest land is part of my farm
New Hampshire is 84% forested yeah there
was Federal lands that are forested but
still in state lands as well but still
that's a again it's just very a very
broad we would as as the committee did
with you the previous bill that I
testified before you early this year
House Bill 1183 you're holding it for
study we'd encourage you to do the same
with this take a look at the the the law
that recently passed in North Dakota
where there the military installation
and there this became a public concern
there's some language in that statute
that enables the leasing of land for
agricultural research purposes which is
something I mentioned to you before that
we would not want that our our State
University should have to pass up an
opportunity to to bring in some some
dollars research dollars to to to uh you
know study a local agricultural uh
concern another area you may want to you
should be aware of is that there there
are a Chinese entities that lease
storage facilities in the state for
we're thinking the purpose of high value
logs where they will purchase these high
value logs store them until they can
ship them back back home over over seas
that that's very lucrative for for land
owners the these these logs it it it's
something that again that that you
should be aware of and look into how
that may be accommodated um and and I
guess just in closing I I also mention
that the the first state to pass a
statute similar to this was in Arkansas
and this past fall there's a a seed
company in Arkansas that it's a it's a
started in Minnesota and then and back
around the 1895 something like that and
eventually it be it's now a wholly own
Subs subsidiary of senta which is a a
senta is a it's a basically a Swiss
company that is is is headquartered in
Switzerland that was purchased by chem
chinina in
2016 something like that anyway because
this of that that line for the seed
company they are now they be they have
two years to sell the 60 Acres of of
research land that they own that company
is my understanding is there are all uh
American workers most of them live in
the local community they were the uh if
not the largest one of the largest
contributors to the FFA in the state of
Arkansas and it again it's just not it's
not clear cut and dried as to you know
the the Chinese control in some
situations and that's why we believe it
though we do support again support the
int
that that you do need to look into some
of these other uh areas that we almost
it's where it it just doesn't make sense
for us as a as a country uh you know to
to be to be restricting this that
broadly and and again though again we do
support the the intent I'll leave it at
that thank you for your time and
attention thank you very
much okay I think we're all set having
no more cards it will close the public
hearing on 366 and go right into our
next
Bild
right um Taran did did you feel out of C
sometimes I'm just
not okay we will open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 423 and hear from
the prime sponsor Senator Carson good
morning Senator Carson good morning Mr
chairman and good morning members of the
House Commerce Committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 comprising the towns of Auburn London
Dair in Hudson and this morning for your
consideration I have Senate Bill 423
relative to mandatory disclosure of
insurance policy limits as you can
probably tell there are a lot of uh
people in the insurance company that are
behind us so um I think you're going to
have an an interesting day already um
every day is exciting with this well I I
looked at your docket and and you you've
got everything from the the land issue
now this IVF you're just getting a
little bit of everything so I I imagine
that keeps things interesting Mr
chairman um Mr chairman this bill um is
about the disclosure of insurance limits
um it has
significantly CH it has changed um from
the Senate when we had the Senate
hearing I listened very carefully to the
issues concerning the insurance
companies um it originally would have
applied to all businesses and and every
kind of situation
but uh again we heard a lot of
complaints about that so it it changed
in two ways number one it is
significantly narrowed to only deal with
motor vehicle accidents and there was
some concerns that were V uh voiced
about protecting um an insurer's policy
and uh and their privacy and language
was put in there that does that but what
does this what does this bill really do
and I don't know if people are aware of
the fact that if you get into an
automobile accident that in order to get
information about the other person's
policy you actually have to get an
attorney and
Sue that seems to be pretty
outrageous why should you have to do
that and what this bill does is it makes
it easier for an individual to get that
information and request it
there's a saying Mr chairman that
information is
power and there's a concern on the
behalf of the insurance industry that if
you as someone who's been injured find
out about the other person's policy
limits that you're going to go you're
going to go for the whole
thing nothing can be further from the
truth I think those of you that have
been on Commerce for a while know that
there's a number of factors that are in
play when someone does make an Insurance
claim against somebody and um I will
talk about those in a few minutes
but when it comes to a failure to
divulge the policy limits um what could
happen is you could have a judgment
that's in excess of that policy limit
that's that's one of the chances that an
individual takes or a company takes when
they do not give you that
information um
as the argument goes revealing liability
limits could have avoided this liability
beyond the applicable limits of the
available
Insurance in many states an insurer's
failure failure to reveal policy limits
at the pre-litigation stage can serve as
a basis for a thirdparty bad faith claim
furthermore because of a failure to
disclose policy limits could be
instrumental in resolving a conflict of
Interest favoring the insurance
company's economic interests over those
of its policyholders and insurer a
liability carer that refuses to Li
reveal their limits again could be
exposing themselves to a bad faith claim
whether or not to reveal and insurers
liability policy limits is a sensitive
issue because it lays bare a point
within the claims process where the
interest of the insurer
which favors the insurer not to reveal
policy limits diverge those of the
insured and this is a revelation um
which AIDS the settlement and may
prevent actual
litigation a demand for policy limits is
routinely alleged to be necessary in
order to properly evaluate and settle a
case that I think is extremely important
most people will settle they'll work
they'll they'll work with the others
insurance company they might hire an
attorney but they they're going to aim
for settlement you will see people that
will sue for large amounts of money and
it depends upon the type of damage
that's happened to you as an individual
you might have sustained serious um uh
physical injury very expensive medical
claims ongoing treatment all of those
things are considered but if you have to
fire hire an attorney to even begin the
process I I I just personally I don't
think that that's appropriate I think
you should be able to get that
information um if a settlement demand is
within policy limits the demand is
rejected and the insure the injured
excuse me the insured experiences a
judgment in excess of policy limits for
which the insurance company refused to
identify and quite frankly a bad faith
claim is going to follow this bill is
necessary because of all 50 states New
Hampshire is only one of four that does
not have a bad faith cause of action
that might be triggered by an insurance
company not disclosing policy limits to
a
plaintiff New Hampshire is the only New
England state that does not require pres
disclosure of policy limits
the language that was amended in this
bill comes from uh one of our
neighboring states and we know that in
New Hampshire the vast majority of civil
cases will settle
pre-trial this saves time and money for
all parties involved without having to
go through costly
litigation there may be a concern that
if an injured person knows the policy
limits um that uh will become the amount
to be claimed in the case I've already
mentioned that but that is quite frankly
unfounded a person's damages in a case
are determined by many factors such as
medical bills lost wages pain and
suffering the assessment of Damages will
need to be supported by evidence you
have to have evidence you have to have
proof of the injuries you have to have
proof of the medical
bills the assessment of Damages will
need to be again supported by evidence
simply knowing what the policy limits
are in a case does not change those
calculations this bill simply ensures
that a person injured by a person with
insurance coverage available to them
knows how much insurance coverage is
available to cover the claim Senate Bill
423 does not impact the cost of Damages
it merely informs the injured person
whether the person who caused their
injury has enough insurance this bill
makes disclosure mandatory without
having to file a lawsuit and will
encourage judicial economy um Mr
chairman at this point I think I'm going
to uh conclude my testimony um and I
will be happy to try to answer any
questions thank you any questions
represent
MC thank you Mr chairman the the last
time I remember dealing with this was
when thank you senator for taking my
question for bringing the bill back um I
think the last time we dealt with it was
when your husband was my vice chair on
this committee so 20 some years ago and
uh we had a a learned colleague um
representative defia who was super
knowledgeable on this issue and we
studied it and for whatever reason it
didn't go forward but 20 years has
passed and I in since then about 19
states have enacted it so in the 31
states that haven't um what I'm
wondering is do the is the practice for
the insurance companies will they just
tell you if it's a low limit because
it'll make you go away and they'll
settle for nuisance money so the
implication being that if it's a high
limit
um you know they may not want to
disclose it and so you can infer the
opposite is is true and right they so if
they if they are Deep Pockets they may
be less likely to disclose and if it's
510 or 1020
that does that make sense okay I I thank
you for the question I think I
understand it I think it's important to
realize what really happens is you have
to hire an attorney first in order to
get that what the policy limit is so
this says you don't have to hire the
attorney if you make the request they
have to tell you that's what this bill
does if you find out early without
having to file an file a case in court
in order order to get them to divulge
you could work towards a settlement
earlier not involve attorneys you figure
it out if you want to hire an attorney
fine but I find it egregious that you
have to hire an attorney in order to
find out what the limit is and there's a
formula as to how your CH uh what you've
gone through your pain your suffering
you've got bills you just can't pull a
number out of the air you're going to
find out what the policy limit is anyway
at the end of the day but why should you
the injured party have to hire an
attorney in order to find out what that
policy limit is why do you have to file
on attorne that's the issue you're going
to find out but in order to find out you
have to hire an attorney you have to sue
to get that why should you get that why
should you do have to go through that I
think the the issue he was pointing out
was that if you request and they tell
you know without without having go to
lawsuit and they tell you well the
limits are only 50,000 you know does
they have a minimum policy
5025 but that if they don't tell
you that should tell you something right
there that if they don't tell you that
means they're probably like me and have
an umbrella and frankly I'm not sure I
really want you to know that I have an
umbrella but you'll figure it out real
quick when you see the lawyer that I
show up
with is my insurance company's lawyer
I Mr chairman I understand that but I
don't think that the average person
should have to hire an attorney got it
that that is I I think that's just
egregious you're going to find out in
the end anyway the only problem I have
with your point is the whole reason this
bill is in front of you is because there
has to be a law the end of the day there
is absolutely a a I identify what kind
of lawyer but it's a lawyer you've hired
to help you win this case to get
compensation you have already hired a
lawyer you already have that lawyer now
if that lawyer says well I'm going to
charge you 250 bucks to file this claim
that's just part of the legal bill that
that lawyer is probably going to say is
I'll get half of it once we get our
settlement so I'm I your your whole
issue is saying we have to hire H I'm
just saying is I doubt there's anybody
that is ever in this situation that
wasn't going to hire a lawyer at all and
now only has to hire a lawyer just to
find out the ends that the reality is in
any of these cases there's always you
always have to hire a lawyer well thank
you for that but I I think it's kind of
hard to come to that conclusion Mr
chairman because you have to F you have
to hire a lawyer to begin with you have
to hire the lawyer to find out what
about the insurance policy you have to
hire a lawyer no matter what
and so if it is that low number you you
give people the opportunity to settle
right no say number they'll tell you
they'll be more than willing to
generously tell you that number it's
only when it's not a high it's a high
number that's when they're little being
a little koi and not so excited about
telling you and about it Mr chair the
testimony we had is they don't divulge
anything they do not voluntarily give
you you a limit that is the testimony we
had in the Senate so I just had a uh
someone uh call me and told me
differently said that often they are
told are they on the record Mr chairman
uh I I I don't see their cart that is
true they haven't filed a cart in here
but they called me and told me in known
certain terms that they're that if the
number's low enough that absolutely the
appraiser probably tells them you know
the adjuster we'll tell them what the
limits are okay representative Ammon has
a question sure thank you Mr chair thank
you senator for taking a question and
you actually touched on the gist of my
question if if someone has a a
homeowners policy or an umbrella policy
um is that included are they included in
this definition of insur uh for this
bill this only deals with automobile
insurance so it would just it's just
automobile insurance um when the bill
was originally filed it would have
included everything but we heard from
businesses that they were very very
concerned about this and so we said okay
what what is the most contact that you
would ever have and it usually is some
sort of automobile accident um your
car's been uh I don't want to say
injured but it's you've sustained some
sort of damage to your vehicle or you
have been injured in some way that's
what most people experience so we we
just focused on automobile insurance and
we also heard from the
insurers um and the changes that we made
are reflected in this bill and it's
unfortunate that um they they're just
not interested in any kind of a
compromise and you can tell when they
come forward to testify and that's very
disappointing it truly is I just have a
follow-up question
um how how is the insurance company of
the other party how is it disclosed uh
you know I guess it could be in a police
report but is it is it mandatory for the
the other party that you're potentially
trying to get damages from to tell you
who their insurance company is and in
what what circumstances does that happen
there's no law saying that they have to
tell you um we do not have mandatory car
insurance in the state of New Hampshire
we don't have an insurance card that we
have to carry somewhere in the vehicle
so if you get into some sort of
automobile accident you present your
card to show that you have proof of
insurance right there is the information
but we don't do that here in New
Hampshire so if the other party
voluntarily gives you that information
that's great you've got a place to start
but there's no requirement that they
disclose information to you at
all uh except if you drive out of state
you better have one right well that's Mr
chairman we can only make laws for the
state of New Hampshire we can't we can't
make every every surrounding State as
great as we are right represent for
taking my question and this is relative
to the Chairman's point about that
you're going to have to hire a law
lawyer anyway isn't it true that there
are a significant number of people who
they're not going to hire a lawyer
because a lawyer is going to ask for a
retainer up front and they're going to
say it's $250 an hour minimum and
there's no guarantee that you're going
to win the case and that they're going
to you know unless they take it on a
contingency so there a lot of people
can't come up with that is that not true
yes that is true thank
you represent M again to to the point I
think someone just me mentioned what
happens and actually happened to me um
what happens if both parties are from
New Hampshire and in in the case for for
me the accident happened on Paka
Boulevard One Night in LOL Massachusetts
both insured myself and the other guy
that hit me head on uh were from New
Hampshire and as the case may be when I
asked the question by the way the first
visitor to the hospital the next morning
was one of those lawyers you mentioned
that I didn't hire and true true story I
didn't hire um what happens then and I
asked the question what because he asked
the question find out what your policy
limits s and call me back uh and I asked
the question and they told me uh and
then days later they reluctantly said
well there's something that we haven't
told you and that's you're both insured
by
metti which was so we are there's no
subreg we're negotiating against
ourselves and they did eventually
disclose the the policy
limit uh which was crazily the same for
both parties so what happens then do
happened in Massachusetts both policies
were New Hampshire residents he was from
Nashville I was from marac thank you for
the question I am not an expert in
insurance and I am not an expert in the
laws of
Massachusetts um we know that each state
does things differently so I really
can't answer that question um but there
are folks here that I think if you were
to pose that question that could
probably answer that question and I
don't want to give the committee
misleading or bad
information it it was an oddball and uh
thank you very much okay uh we'll call
on the thank you very much oh thank you
Mr chairman uh call on the insurance
department it Senator Carson do you have
written testimony that you can put in
some notes okay no problem thank you
yeah uh good morning my name is uh James
Fox I'm the uh property and casualy
director at the New Hampshire insurance
department and I'm joined here uh by
Emily dhy who's the property casualty uh
attorney at the
department um the department uh opposes
the bill on uh two grounds first grounds
we feel it's unnecessary based on the
current state of Law and we also feel it
is a financial privacy invasion of
policy holders I mean the law talks
about claimants and it talks about
insurance companies but the other entity
involved is the policy holder as to why
it's unnecessary um there's really two
two phases there's like a front-end
phase and then the back end phase on the
front end auto insurance uh as those
you've been here a while know is is
unique in New Hampshire it's not like
figuratively unique or kind of it is
unique we have a unique system here and
our system is designed so that when you
buy an in an auto insurance policy you
are able to protect yourself so you
choose your limits for liability so if
you go out and you hit someone in low
Massachusetts those would be your
liability limits of the person you hit
uh but uh what you get with that in New
Hampshire since we don't have mandatory
Insurance uh is that you get an equal
amount of uninsured motorist coverage so
if you're concerned about uh that you
might get into an accident you might be
injured your first line of defense is to
have uh a high liability limit which
would then give you a high uninsured
motorist coverage so if the person you
hit if they have a
2550 uh small policy but you have say a
single limit 500,000 then you're going
to have 500,000 fear injuries uh and
then lay it on top of that you then
could get uh uh as
a chairman hunt said a uh an umbrella
policy uh but that's the first line um
that that's really how the our whole
state systems been designed uh over the
years is that since we don't have
mandatory uh auto insurance the design
is that you are able to protect yourself
but I understand that not everybody can
afford a high 500 you know a high policy
with with an umbrella so then we have
another layer uh of protection uh that
we have at the department and that's
called 417 415 it's called unfair claims
practices so that is how we uh handle
the issue of how the insurance company
uh interacts with the uh
claimants
and the first line is they have to
before they settle we require them to do
a reasonable investigation and so just
keep that on a simple level I think
someone mentioned a police report before
uh if an if an insurance company tried
to settle early and settle low if
there's a significant injury and they
say they didn't get a a a police report
then eventually we do what's called an
examination and then every time they've
done that they get fined on that every
time $2,500 $2,500 $2,500 and then they
have to get an action plan to make sure
they don't do that again and then the
next line uh and the next section uh
that's three section four is they have
to equitably be settled they have to
settle fairly so if they're not settling
fairly with you again that's another
violation of the unfair insurance claims
Practices Act and it is true that
generally how from the Department's uh
perspective how this generally does work
is if you have a low limits e it could
be one of two things you either have a
low limits policy and then just going to
tell you it's a 2550 um will you know
they're willing to settle with you if
you're willing to you know sign a a a
settlement a release uh or you could
have a serious situation like uh uh
somebody died and then even if it's a
higher policy they they say look this is
what we have um we are willing to settle
for that amount uh but again if it is a
if it is a high amount then they tend
not to do that um and the department uh
understands that so as they said earlier
in auto insurance you're able to protect
yourself and then I always say you
should protect yourself and you know is
have the highest limits you can have
because that you know if you actually
get if you see get seriously hurt if you
end up in a wheelchair you're going to
want to have high limits um but uh if
this bill were to pass there is a
concern uh that now saying that you
would you know the people the the
proponents of this bill may be uh great
people and not not doing that but there
might be some other attorneys out there
who may use it uh as as a leverage to
say oh you know we're going to work this
more to get the get the number up and
and that's a concern so then we'd have
to change our you know get as much
insurance as you can to protect yourself
to you know there is a possibility you
you will have to disclose your limit so
you may have to consider that also also
um and then uh and before I forget so
this I'm talking about 4174 so there's
also uh one other provision that says um
they're not supposed to offer you a
settlement substantially lower than the
value of what your claim is that that
was added not too long ago uh but the
other the other issue is I think someone
mentioned this this is currently in the
the new version which is you must uh you
must disclosed limits is currently uh
seated in the department of safety's um
law that would not be if you wanted to
go down that road that would not be the
right location for it it would be 4174
because what you basically done is put
something in the department of safey law
that is an insurance conduct issue which
they don't really handle they they do
financial responsibility which is how
much you have but they don't do conduct
and you also gave the department of
safety um the ability to find the
insurance companies um for that conduct
issue so that that that's always been um
with the uh insurance
department um and also would add and
know there was something that somebody
said that you needed to have an attorney
uh to to get your limits that that is
not true there's there's that's not in
the law anywhere so basically uh if you
ask uh and it's a it's it's a low
whether you have a your the limits are
low you should get the answer uh and uh
you know as I always said we're going
through all of these issues and there
are laws we have a group of people at
the insurance department called the
consumer Division and so if anybody here
has a has a problem with an insurance
company they don't feel like they're
being handled the the claims being
handled correctly you can call the
insurance department and we will help
you work through the claim uh and if we
feel that the uh insurance company has
uh violated uh the unfair claims
Practices Act again on an individual
basis on a one claim consumer claim so
not want doing exams we'll also find
them in that context so all of this is
designed to make sure that the insurance
company um does what they're supposed to
do uh we don't feel that there's going
to be any added protection uh if if you
have a disclosure limits what you're
going to have if you say is a mandatory
disclosure limits is you're going to
have you're going to run a file of ins
3000 ins 3000 is one of our rules and
the rule basically protects the
financial information of policy holders
so obviously insurance companies are to
a certain extent a lot of States they're
regulated by the same entity like Banks
uh and so just like Banks and insurance
companies we do not want them giving out
the private uh financial information of
uh residents of the State of New
Hampshire so in that they usually how it
works is they have to give they explain
how they're going to use your
information but if you want to opt out
you're allowed to opt out and say don't
don't give my information out to anybody
uh and so they they really currently if
you ask them to do that they should not
be giving out your limits because you've
asked them not to um and then the last
thing some somebody mentioned uh uh that
this is from another state I believe
it's Maine and again we said how unique
New Hampshire is uh in Auto World Maine
is not like that main is a completely
different regulatory structure so if you
you wanted to do that you probably would
need to bring the whole main regulatory
structure over you shouldn't do it like
peace meal because we have a system in
New Hampshire the department feels it
works very well and it protects the
residence of the State of New Hampshire
and we would like it to remain as is and
I'm happy to take any questions
great representative burrow thanks for
taking my question I just want to make
sure I understood you correctly are you
saying that if somebody wants to know
the limit they can get it as long as the
other party hasn't opted out a financial
disclosure or did I misunderstand that
what I was saying is somebody said you
have to have an attorney uh you don't
have to have an attorney to that's not a
standard to get to get the limits if as
it's been expressed here it's accurate
if if the party has a very low limit and
you have a serious claim the insurance
company wants to wants to end it too if
if you're willing to take the the low
limit and not go any further and maybe
you have you have your own uninsured
motorist they're going to tell you that
the the limit of the the tort feaser in
this case is only 2550
um we'll just give you the limits and
then you go to your insurance company
when you have a much higher policy then
you say h i they offer you the 20 the
2550 I'd like to take that and I'd like
to make an uninsured Motors claim and
then they say okay then you go down the
road and your uninsured Motors claim and
that's why uh if you have if you're able
you should have a high limit on your
uninsured Motors claim uninsured Motors
limits on your policy so just all I'm
saying is that the the way the world
works is that if you have if it's a
somebody has a low limit and the
insurance think company thinks they can
get out they will tell you those limits
if some somebody has a very high limit
then there are a lot other other
variables that come into play and the
insurance company is not as willing to
to to tell you those the limits because
they're they are afraid right or wrong
Target any other questions thank you
very much thank
sorry for the record Israel Piedra um
I'm an attorney in Nashua at welz White
and Fontaine a law firm I live in
Manchester I was a member of the house
for two
terms um I'm here to testify in favor of
this
bill the first thing I'll say is that it
really is a small bill in my mind it's
not world changing it's a technical fix
it makes a small but meaningful Common
Sense change and it will improve access
to justice for folks in New Hampshire in
again a small but meaningful way so
that's the first thing I want to frame
we're not changing the world here but I
do think it's a step in the right
direction and I'll explain why so why do
we need this so the typical example is
someone comes into my office they're a
client they were injured in a car
accident as an attorney we make a
valuation an evaluation about what that
claim might be worth and so I might
advise the client I don't think that you
should settle for less than
$60,000 you were out of work for a month
you incurred tens of thousands of
dollars in medical
bills I think that your claim is worth
$60 ,000 so we present that information
to the other driver who was at fault
their insurance company and they make an
offer of
$50,000 now under current New Hampshire
law which we're trying to change the
insurance
adjuster may know that the insured
policy limits is $50,000 and that's the
maximum they can offer but they don't
have to tell me that and in fact as you
just heard from the insurance
department apparently under current law
there not allowed to tell you that um
and so there is in fact in practice
some differences of of of of how that
works in practice some insurance
adjusters will give you that information
voluntarily but under current law as we
just heard from the insurance department
they're actually not supposed to and in
fact sometimes they don't so now you're
in a situation where your client has
been offered $50,000 Which is less than
what you've told them that their claim
is worth and as an attorney you
ethically cannot recommend that they
take that settlement for $50,000 unless
you know for a fact that's all the money
that's available so now what happens is
you have to draft a lawsuit on their
behalf that'll take a few weeks you
filed the lawsuit with the court pay
$300 odd dollar $280 in filing fees to
the court you give it to the sheriff pay
the sheriff to serve it on the defendant
some person in their house gets served
by the sheriff even though they're
insured then you go into court the
insurance company has to hire a
lawyer they file an answer and then a
month later under current New Hampshire
statute and Court rule they are then
required to tell us hey the insurance
policy limit is only $50,000 that's all
you can get and then you settle the case
for $50,000 because that's all you can
get you could have avoided that drafting
the lawsuit waiting weeks serving with
the sheriff having to interrupt some po
person at their home even though they
have insurance weeks waiting in the
court system bured on the court
insurance company having to hire a
lawyer all to reach the same result
because under current statute which is
498 colon
2-a once suit is filed the insurance
company is required to disclose their
policy limits we're just asking that we
go back a few weeks or months to the the
moment where we're trying to settle the
case without having to go through all
that trouble and require them to
disclose it then that's all we're asking
for and it really doesn't make much of a
difference to lawyers we get paid the
same no matter whether we settle two
months ago or two months in the in the
future it makes a difference to our
clients because a they have to pay for
those court costs which are not a lot
but it's a few hundred dollar to to to
file a lawsuit and to pay a sheriff to
serve the lawsuit and it makes more of a
difference because of the time the time
to draft the lawsuit to have it served
to wait for the insurance company to
hire a lawyer and respond and then
finally disclose that information we
should have had a couple months ago and
these people often are living paycheck
to paycheck they haven't worked for a
long time they have medical bills that
might be going to collections and they
need the money and all this bill would
do um would be to help them get that
money which they're going to get anyway
a little bit sooner um so I really think
it's a common sense fix it's a
relatively minor fix that just speeds up
the process by a few few weeks or months
and helps get money into injured
people's hands that they're going to get
anyway a little bit quicker I'm happy to
answer any
questions representative
burs thank you I just have a quick
question thanks for taking my question
the example you gave where the insurance
company had a $50,000 limit what if
somebody has an accident and they have
$3 million worth of medical bills do
they I mean can they not they cannot get
more than 50,000 well and I I won't go
into a lot of detail about underinsured
motorist coverage which the
representative from the insurance
department talked about if there's no if
the person who is injured if I'm
uninsured and I'm hit by someone else
and they only have $50,000 in coverage
in most cases yes now that's an extreme
example with $3 million a catastrophic
type injury and those situations Al laer
will still do their due diligence to to
make sure that there's no other assets
that the defendant has if they own
multiple houses for example or they're
somehow rich in some other way there's
no uh there's no rule that you can't go
past that insurance C coverage limit and
pursue them personally but what happens
in practice is if someone only has
$50,000 of coverage they probably don't
have multiple houses they probably don't
have a bank account with a million
dollars in it and they have protection
under certain laws including bankruptcy
laws that make it really unfeasible to
get more than that $50,000 limit in
almost every situation thank you and
that's
horrifying represent M uh thank you um
just a quick question you you mentioned
uninsured how about underinsured and in
this case if I had a million dollars
worth of my own liability coverage and
he only had uh 50 could we dip into that
a absolutely and so again the way that
underinsured coverage works is typically
that it only kicks in the ins again the
insurance department uh representative I
think mated things it's not the first
line of defense legally it's the second
line of defense you're required to
exhaust the tort fees or defendants
insurance coverage before you get to dip
into your own coverage it's a backup um
and so what would happen in that
situation is again you still need to
have that insurance coverage limit
information
um in order to settle with the Tor fees
or the defendant first before you get to
dip into your own coverage um so this
bill would help in that situation too
where right now you might have to
actually bring a lawsuit waste your time
getting that $50,000 before you realize
you have to turn to your own insurance
if this law if this bill is passed that
information gets disclosed up front and
you immediately know hey I need to make
an underinsured claim against my own
insurance
enough okay thank you very much thank
good morning chairman hunt and members
of the committee you get me today
instead of George my name is Lindsay
NATO I am an attorney at Orin Reno here
in conquer and we represent the um State
trade and the national trade groups for
the Property and Casualty insurers
that's the New Hampshire Association of
domestic insurance companies as well as
the American Property Casualty Insurance
Association
and we are here in opposition to Senate
Bill
423 um I just wanted to clear one thing
up I don't think currently there's an
issue in practice and we I think it's
Undisputed and there's correspondence
from the bill proponents and testimony
and also from industry that the majority
of the time if there's a legitimate
request pre- lawsuit for a policy limit
disclosure that information is
voluntarily provided
already now are there times when perhaps
the information isn't provided yes but
there's good reason for that and we
don't think
mandating policy information no
questions asked is a good policy
decision so we'd ask you not to vote for
the
bill so as initially drafted as you
heard the bill allowed anyone to make a
request for any reason to any person or
their business about their policy limits
it then was narrowed down to just Auto
liability
policies um this is still in our view an
unnecessary burden and frankly just a
violation of privacy to those businesses
and individuals carrying Auto liability
policies and umbrella
policies it's in the interest as you've
already heard for all parties to settle
cases um without the expense of
litigation and having to hire
attorneys claims get settled every day
without attorneys invol involved I've
had them personally I've been in an auto
accident I did not have to hire an
attorney um so generally this is not a
problem the voluntary the information is
voluntarily provided when there's good
reason to do so so for example when a
claimant's injuries are valued higher
than the policy limits it may be in the
insured's best interest to disclose the
policy limits to help expedite a faster
resolution to a claim and allow the
claimant to pursue their uninsured
underinsured motorist coverage and
that's typically when these situations
come up so if you have $200,000 in
Damages and a $50,000 policy limit the
insurer is going to say it's a $50,000
policy go use your own um
coverage but claims should really be
based on alleged injuries and damages
your policy limit really shouldn't come
into play a mandatory disclosure of
policy limits may actually become an
impediment in resolution if the
plaintiff's lawyer is aware of a high
dollar policy limit and then focuses on
that limit rather than their actual de
damages so keep in mind also that
whether to disclose or not to disclose
is really up to the insurance company
whose duty is to protect their insured
it's not to um serve the interests of a
potential claimant who's seeking to sue
you so from the company's perspective
that relationship is between the company
and their insured and that's where their
Duty lies and I think that's where came
up Mr Fox mentioned ins 3000 and as part
of that Duty confidentiality
requirements and insurance C companies
can't just go around giving out your
personal information right um and under
the RS there are times when they can
disclose that information and that would
be these scenarios so this bill would
conflict with that because the insurer
would have to give out the information
even if you don't authorize them to do
that um and James Fox will correct me if
I misstated that um so if there are rare
situations when a company is not
disclosing in a a limit for some reason
like if liability isn't clear or
claimant hasn't provided a legitimate
reason for requesting it a claimant May
file a lawsuit and will automatically
receive that information as part of the
discovery process very early in the
litigation court and we already heard
there's a statutory requirement and then
there's also state and federal court
requirements this bill is really
one-sided and unlike in a number of
states a potential claimant is not
required to produce any information
about the request they can just say show
me your limit they don't have to provide
you any information about their damages
a police report medical records grounds
for liability there isn't a strict
confidentiality provision there aren't
any um clarifications in this bill that
the information can't be used if the
case does go to court these are all
Mutual disclosure requirements that we
often see in the minority of states that
do have a resuit mandate there's a
mutual disclosure
requirement that's not what this bill
does it's completely
onesided transparency is a two-way
street so if a potential defendant is
required to disclose information then we
believe a potential plaintiff should
also be required to do the same the
majority of States remember do not
require preuit disclosure of policy
limits New Hampshire protects its
privacy we have a constitutional
amendment on privacy um and we feel like
this is an invasion of those privacy
rights frankly it's no one's business
how much Insurance you carry if this
bill were to say how much do you have in
your bank
account I don't think you'd be in favor
of that and that's essentially what this
bill does it invites fishing Expeditions
so that you know how deep someone's
pockets are so in Most states like New
Hampshire currently the nature and
amount of insurance that you carry is
private it's not subject to public
disclosure and we believe that's um that
status quo should be
held so the bill would subject people in
businesses to the burden of contacting
their insurance agent or their company
to confirm their coverage guess what
coverages might apply without even
potentially knowing what they're accused
of doing um and therefore we believe
that any utility of the legislation is
outweighed by its costs and we hope that
you will find it inexpedient to
legislate
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony uh any
committee okay seeing none thank you
thank
you next we're going to call
up Heather men men menzes from
nhj and you support the bill and you
request two
minutes thank you to the committee again
my name is Heather Meneses I'm an
attorney with Shaheen and Gordon um and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
uh and I am speaking in support of uh
this bill um to help me understand a
little further I I am a personal injury
attorney so I'll let you know how the
process goes and then why this bill
really is necessary um say somebody
comes in there a car accident and
they're
injured we investigate that claim the I
don't take a retainer I do all my cases
on contingency fee as most attorneys
like me do um so we have to investigate
we get their records I get their records
from before the accident to make sure
they're not already experiencing the
these issues um and then we make a claim
with the insurance company now most
insurance companies are not the ones
getting fined like Mr Fox said most they
negotiate with you and we're able to
resolve a case um and you know the value
of the case is what that investigation
that I put into it it it's not dependent
on what the policy limits are so so why
do we need them what's the big deal then
so this is where the the issues come
into play one where you've got say
you've got someone very seriously
injured and I'm doing my due diligence
I'm getting all the records all the
bills I am providing them this is not
one-sided I'm giving all this
information to the insurance company um
and
and I'm doing all this work say the
person only has 50,000 in coverage and
they have 100,000 in medical bills why
am I going to keep doing all this stuff
if there's only 50,000 uh and I've had
and I have had to file suit because they
wouldn't give it give up the the policy
limits were only to find out why didn't
you just tell me this but the most
important impact I think and it's as Mr
Fox explained um representative um
macaller also mentioned is underinsured
motorist coverage and
again under you have underinsured
coverage if someone causes you
injury and you know you say I you have a
million dollar umbrella coverage
yourself if you don't know how much
coverage that person who caused your
injury has you don't know whether you
have an underinsured motorist case or
not you can't compare unless you know um
and had to file a lawsuit because the
insurance company hasn't done that I had
a case where the person themselves had
$1.25 million in coverage you had a
permanent brain injury and will never
work again insurance company wouldn't
tell me I had to file suit because I
literally could not determine what what
whether he had an underinsured M his
coverage um and under the court rules
you get them automatically you get the
you don't even have to request it you
get what the policy limits are um and uh
so it was a waste it was an absolute
waste um it wastes the burden of the
court because now they have to give you
a docket number jury trial date all of
that um we have to spend the money to
file the
lawsuit but then also you want to talk
about privacy who's the defendant in
that lawsuit I filed the individual the
insurance company is not on the other
side of that V that is Mr Jones who
caused the accident is now public record
anyone can look that up and see he's
been sued there's your privacy issue
right there um meanwhile if the
insurance company had just said oh yeah
well they also have 1.25 million in
coverage I know I have no underinsured
motorist claim now and I didn't have to
file that lawsuit that's why this is
necessary um like like um uh the
attorney before me said you know yeah a
lot of times this is voluntarily done
yes it is and it's a very simple process
um I request the policy limits and they
just give them to me it's not burdensome
on the insurance company they have that
information uh and it's not as though I
say oh I think this is a $50,000 claim
oh you have a million dollars now it's a
million dollar claim it's not a million
dollar claim it's a $50,000 claim and we
never even touch the rest of that
coverage that's how that goes in
practice um and I'm happy happy to
answer any questions about how this goes
in practice all right thank you very
much um you have a question
representative
portelli so can you tell thank you for
taking my question so can you tell me
what protections there are um legally to
make sure that you're that you're not
when you get the information about the
insurance limits that you're not trying
to increase the value of the lawsuit so
if you only have 50,000 and find out the
you know the other party has a million
you say okay we're going to get a big
payday what are the what are the um uh
processes in place that would prohibit
something like that so the I would say
the processes are the fact that the
insurance industry they're smart people
right and we have to prove our claim
so if I make a claim say it's really
only a
$50,000 uh case and it's a million doll
policy say I make a million dollar
demand they're not going to pay it
they're going to say where's your
evidence and if I don't have it that
case isn't going to settle um as a
practical matter a as a personal injur
attorney I substantiate every demand
that I make I don't just say I want a
million dollars I say look here are the
elements of my claim lost wages are x
amount and I write to the employer to
get substantiation for that medical
bills are this amount here's all the
bills here's all the medical records and
the and this is an exchange this is not
a one-way street it's an exchange we're
giving a lot of information to these
insurance adjusters pruit for them to be
able to make a determination as to what
the case should resolve for um and
they're smart they're good at their jobs
um they've
settled cases before just as I have and
and that's how the process goes um and I
and no attorney worth their salt is
going to make some ridiculous demand
because they know they're not going to
get a response to it and I think that's
where the protection is is that the the
industry knows what it's doing um and
and attorneys themselves aren't just
going to make some crazy demand because
then nothing's going to happen and it'll
be a waste of everybody's time I have a
question
um currently the attorney doesn't know
the policy limits most likely before
they accept the suit right before they
take the case correct usually so if so
my question is uh if let's say someone
has a million dooll legitimate claim but
the policy limit is only 250,000 so
there's 750,000 above the
claim and the attorney knows that in
advance before they accept their
client's
case wouldn't it be harder for someone
to get get an attorney to accept the
case if the attorney knows in advance
that the claim is far Bey beyond the
policy limits because it's much harder
to get assets from someone than it is a
payout from the an insurance company
there's a lot more work for the attorney
so couldn't it could it unfairly
Advantage the attorney to know that
information before they accept the case
because they would they would accept
easy cases and maybe not accept more
difficult cases where assets are
required right right and I I think
understand your question if if as I
answer it it's clear I'm not I'm happy
to to to try again but so the the
situation is is that there's only
250,000 in coverage but there's a
million dollars in Damages and so what
happens with that person honestly I've
had cases where if we know what that
coverage is I I don't take the case I
don't take the case just to take like
the 250,000 if the person could have
gotten it on their own anyway um so so
that's that's one advantage there is
that person then if that 250 is offered
to them they don't need me um yeah so
I'm sorry that that was my question okay
so there's a million-- dollar legitimate
claim like in in uh in in the
metaphysical world that person deserves
a million dollars but there's only a
small amount of coverage the attorney
knows that before accepting the case
they may they may not have they may not
accept that case that person may have a
harder time getting an attorney oh oh so
I see what you're saying so um I think
it's going to depend on the
circumstances but if if that's something
then we
learn for me I would just have the
person take the 250 if we know that
that's all that's there and the
insurance company just pays it and
there's no litigation now if the person
wants to investigate are their personal
assets a lot of people don't know they
have underinsured motorist coverage as
well they they know oh well I know I
have $250 and a $1 million umbrella but
that's liability they don't know that in
New Hampshire you automatically have
underinsured coverage um and a lot of
time we can also look more broadly too
to see what other insurance does exist
um so you know it I think it depends on
the circumstances it depends on what
other assets might be available but I
don't think it would hinder I don't
think that situation would hinder that
person getting an attorney to get what
they would deserve um if they are being
offered the 250 and we know that all
there is is 250 I I will tell you I
wouldn't take the case because I'm not
just going to take a one-third
contingent fee on something I'm not
going to do any work on I would just the
person would just make the claim on the
other person's insurance company and get
the max they can get thank you
representative Bros this is a would you
believe question question um I I know
that many many uh insur and your your
firm may be different in um law firms
who handle these kinds of cases
routinely the first thing they do is
figure out how much money is involved I
mean that's just a fact my husband is
done a lot of work for these firms and
if there's not enough money in it for
them they refer them
elsewhere I don't want to speak to other
no I understand that I understand but it
is a routine practice that's what you
believe representative Gresley
yeah I I I certainly sympathize with
your situation here but I'm I'm looking
for something that that basically makes
a little more sense because I can
understand that if somebody just came in
somebody was in an accident and the
first thing they want to know is what
the insurance limits are so they can
maybe gain their case to get more money
whether it be 50 or $60,000 or or or $5
million is there any way that we can put
an amendment into this bill that would
say that that they have to disclose you
and I understand that when you make a a
claim a lot of them volun arily will
disclose what their limits are but what
we do is we make it a requirement that
when you make your claim so you're
putting your money you you put your
cards on the table first and then
they're required to put their CS before
going to court because I think going to
court is is is senseless in this if we
can settle out of court and that's what
we're trying to do here I think this is
what this bill is trying to do and I
think that if we could put some sort of
trigger in the law that says when you
file your claim that's your claim they
can now come back at you they can tell
you what the limits are and so then you
can start working and and it would
probably keep you out of in 99% of the
cases it'll probably keep you out of
court so the I I think the protection is
the the alternative of what you're
saying is fraud um attorneys can't do
that um I I don't do it most attorneys I
think don't do it um and again I'm going
to go back to the insurance industry and
the insurance
adjusters are very smart and
knowledgeable so they'll be able to
smell that a mile away for sure if
someone is just padding
something to go to I mean someone goes
to their doctor their doctor makes
recommendations and if it's it becomes
pretty obvious if things aren't
legitimate because the everything has to
be substantiated with medical opinion
for injuries or lost wages with you know
usually the employer or some something
um and I think the insurance industry is
very good at what they do and if there
was any hint of that then then uh they
would know
that thank you very much thank you uh
eye good morning chairman hunt members
of the House Commerce Committee thank
you for allowing me to speak this
morning my name is Joan Pao I'm the
president of the big eye of New
Hampshire representing the Independent
Insurance Agents throughout our state
and we strongly oppose Senate Bill
423 when this bill was brought forward
it pertained to all lines of insurance
when our association along with many
other businesses and associations stood
together and opposed this bill they
amended it to include only
automobile we continue to strongly
oppose this bill insurance has been My
Chosen career since
1979 and I've personally been involved
in an auto accident and I've been
treated fairly by the insurers that were
involved I don't believe mine was the
exception I believe insurance carriers
treat their insurance and cl claimants
fairly our insurance processes work
because of that underlying fairness
I'm not an attorney I'll start with that
and I have nothing against attorneys
some of my closest friends are attorneys
and it's my understanding and it's been
brought out several times though when a
suit is filed the insurance limits must
be provided to the claimant's attorney
this makes sense to me this bill makes
it a requirement subject to a penalty in
attorney's fees for non-compliance to
provide liability coverage limits which
would include umbrella limits because
they're an extension of the automobile
limits before a suit has been brought
that doesn't make sense to me I believe
it's unwarranted an invasion of privacy
and for a lack of a better term a
fishing Expedition by the attorney let
me give you an example two car accidents
happen same scenario each time a vehicle
is rear ended and the inj and the
injuries are the same first in both
instances the person struck the claimant
under this bill can now demand to know
your liability limits
no suit being filed is necessary in the
first crash the at fault driver carries
minimum liability limits 2550 for bodily
injury in the second crash the ATA
driver carries
25500 limits for bodily injury plus a $5
million
umbrella whose case do you think the
attorney is going to
take proponents of this bill have said
the passage will streamline the court
process that doesn't makes sense to me I
believe it's naive to think that this
bill could streamline or reduce the
number of lawsuits I believe what it
will do is undermine the insurance
process that works here in New Hampshire
what it will do is cause unnecessary
work for the hardworking insurance
agents who have who will have to feel
demands for coverage limits what it will
do is take away the opportunity from the
Independent Insurance agent to advocate
for their clients with the insurance
carrier because once an attorney is
involved and retained the agents are
taken out of the process so even though
they want to help their clients they
want to be their Advocate they
can't so on behalf of those thousands of
hardworking Independent Insurance Agents
here in New Hampshire I respectfully ask
that you vote Senate Bill 423
inexpedient to legislate I thank you for
your time and I'll be happy to try to
answer any question
question I guess we're all set thank you
Chase checking to see that it's still
morning good morning Representatives um
for the record my name is Marissa Chase
I'm the executive director for the New
Hampshire Association for jus which is a
euphemism for plaintiff's Trial Lawyers
Association um we are in support of this
bill um I just wanted to make two brief
points in Senator Carson's opening
statement and I went back and double-
checked this she was citing um a
narrative from an insurance defense firm
advocating for policies such as Senate
Bill 423 contains the insurance defense
firm I emailed that to the committee um
they 50 state survey it's uh mat wicker
and larer they're a national civil
defense firm I wish we had some more
Insurance defense lawyers here to
testify and explain how the process
works I will share that when I have
spoken to them um they they would agree
that we thought this would be a
no-brainer um I understand that there
are some concerns I would note that this
started off in Senate
Judiciary and perhaps Judiciary is a
better committee that is more familiar
with how um the legal process works so I
understand the questions you have and I
hope that our members are doing our best
to answer those questions um that's all
I wanted to
say fair enough any questions in the
committee members see none thank you
very much thank
Farm good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm Kiren
Schultz I'm an attorney with Nix and PE
based here in the Manchester office uh
some of my practice actually does
include Insurance defense uh but I am
here representing State Farm one of the
leading writers of auto and home
insurance in the nation and also here in
New Hampshire we're here to oppose SB
423 um you've heard from others today
and likely may hear from from more uh
about the reasons that weos oos this
bill um we have share some of their
concerns um and I I will submit written
testimony for the record as well um this
morning but just to summarize its main
points and without repeating too much um
others
testimony um as a practical matter under
current law legitimate claimants can and
do obtain information about liability
coverage limits in the normal course of
a claim at the proper time and State
Farm has a lot of experience working
with similar bills in other states and
has identified a a list of problems with
this bill um first as it's written SB
423 could incentivize targeting of
people who purchase insurance so people
who make the responsible decision to
enter into private contracts for the
purchase of insurance um and it does
raise concerns that climan demands will
be I call it reverse
engineered um meaning they will be
calculated to reflect the full amount or
at least approximating the full amount
of insurance coverage that may be
available rather than the amount that
really properly reflects the alleged
damages suffered by the injured party
which are wholly independent from the
existence or not of insurance coverage
um and to be clear I I I want to be
clear that some lawyers do this lawyers
definitely do this I will exclude from
from uh from that group The the very
well respected uh members of the
plaintiff bar who sit in the first row
here um who do the work to substantiate
their clients claims but not all lawyers
do that unfortunately it would make my
job easier if they did um others seem to
just say you know show me the money
where's the money without doing the work
necessary to substantiate those those
and and State Farm has seen also some
instances for example there's a law that
was fairly recently passed in Colorado
that's similar to this one where State
Farm has noticed instances where uh
requiring disclosure has actually
generated uh medically unnecessary
treatment because attorneys kind of push
their clients to go uh receive
additional Medical Services to pump up
the valuation of their
claims uh so second the also will likely
create some confusing overlap um with
existing court rules and statutes that
require disclosure of the same
information post initiation of
litigation and with different time
frames so right now claimants are
entitled to insurance policy information
after they filed a lawsuit and by the
way filing a lawsuit uh should only be
done for legitimate meritorious claims
but it's not hard it's you something
that any any person any prosay plantiff
can can do without an attorney if they
feel like filing a two or three page
complaint or more longer with the court
and paying a small filing fee um but the
uh the beauty of it is that by filing a
complaint in court the claimant or their
attorney is essentially certifying to
the court that the claims that are
involved in that lawsuit are uh properly
grounded in the law and in fact and
they're not
frivolous um but but yes insurance
information is among the very first
categories of required disclosures in
both state and federal courts the bill
as it's written though seems to allow
anyone to obtain that same otherwise
privately held policy information on
demand without any corollary requirement
that the requests be made in good
faith uh the third problem that State
Farm uh sees with this bill is that it
contains no or only minimal threshold
requirements or guard rails against
frivolous or unmeritorious claims um the
we've talked a little bit about how the
bill is very one-sided and the uh most
recent Amendment adds some minimal guard
rails on the use for example of
disclosed policy limits by saying that
the claimant or claimants attorney shall
utilize the disclosure only in
connection with the claim or lawsuit but
there are no penalties associated with
failure to adhere to that provision
um and if you look at how other states
statutory or regulatory Frameworks deal
with pruit disclosure policy limits um
among the the several states that
require any pre-litigation disclosure of
liability policy limits and by the way
the numbers that I have for you know how
many states actually require these
things and and to what extent seem to
differ uh pretty substantially from the
numbers that Senator Carson had cited
earlier and others so um but
among those States many of them impose
pretty substantial threshold
requirements that are absent from this
bill uh for example a claimant has to
provide certain documents uh or evidence
supporting their claims confidentiality
protections apply to disclosed
information protections against
unnecessary disclosure of excess or
umbrella policy information um uh some
states would also uh restrict to
automobile insurance coverage but they
may also exclude for example Fleet
coverage so there are other
considerations and I I do want to note
that um uh it saddens me to hear Senator
Carson say that uh the the insurance
industry was unable to compromise but I
I want to specifically note that State
Farm did not agree to the amendment
language making the bill applicable to
Auto policies only uh they feel that
improperly targets uh entities like
insurers uh but so just to to to be
clear under new hampsh Under current New
Hampshire law our state is not an
outlier um it's it is it's relatively
few States about 18 plus DC that require
any pres disclosure of liability policy
limits by our uh by our uh research and
and um experience and among these Most
requirements um and um it's also notable
that about eight 18 other states that
have such a law ensure that the severity
of injury warrants the disclosure so I
think in Virginia for example the the
plff has to prove that their medical
bills will exceed the minimum limits for
uh for coverage this bill doesn't have
any such provision there's also a bill
in Delaware that is one example of a
better
alternative and fourth and finally the
penalties in the bill are potentially
severe for insurers and they're one way
only Target tarting the insurer
um uh it's you know we're subjecting an
insurer to a financial pen penalty for
failure to comply which could encourage
some gamesmanship it's not clear when
the 30-day period exactly might start
how many letters can the person send to
trigger it um there's no penalties again
built in for claimant or claimants
council's misuse of the policy info and
the $500 penalty uh I think it was $500
the last time I looked in the new New
Hampshire Bill uh is pretty severe um
and there are perhaps only other I think
three states that impose penalties like
that New Hampshire would be an outlier
if it if it did something like that and
so for these reasons we oppose the bill
and ask the committee to do the same and
I'm happy to answer questions if it
helpful I think they're all questioned
out thank you thank you uh chair we'll
oh red is good okay red is usually bad
in my
business in anybody's business thank you
again Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Roger turge and I
live in Dober New Hampshire I've been a
trial lawyer for 43 years in New
Hampshire mass and Maine I have to be uh
an Governor at large of the nhj our
organization at any given time
represents perhaps 10 to 20,000 citizens
of residents of the State of New
Hampshire involved in Tor claims um I
speak in support of 423 not just for the
nhj but personally I don't have much
skin in the game I'm going to be
retiring anytime I'm speaking on behalf
of those people who will be injured and
have claims coming up in the the future
but they don't know who they are yet so
they can't be here to speak to it they
they don't know they're going to have an
interest in this I support
423 because it's it's mainstream it's a
pretty common type of legislation across
the country and in New England we are
the only state that have doesn't have a
disclosure requirement like this um two
of the states are motor vehicle specific
Connecticut and Vermont and the other
three states are actually have broader
disclosure requirements than we do so
it's mainstream it just makes common
sense it costs nothing to the insurance
companies whatever you've heard about oh
agents might be burdened by half to
responding to these things I can
guarantee you it doesn't it's not agents
the bill talks about insurer an agent is
not an insurer we know who the insurers
are we know who the claims people are
they're the ones who are required to
make the disclosure I guarantee you that
whenever a claim comes to an adjuster's
desk one of the pieces of paper that's
been disclosed to that adjuster actually
it's not paper anymore it's it's on
their screen with their with on their
computer is the policy limits they're
not surprised by it they don't have to
do any extra work to look it up or to
tell anybody upon requests so it costs
nothing it does save litigation as
Israel P padra said it is not an earth
shattering thing this is not going to
change the lives of thousands and
thousands of people in New Hampshire but
there are occasions where because we the
claimant can't find out the policy
number the policy limit or the
claimant's lawyer can't find out the
policy limit we have to file a suit to
find out um what that number is that's
represents a small expense that's going
to be passed on to the client it
represents an expense for the insurance
company that's greater because now they
have to hire a lawyer or they're paying
you know they've got a lawyer on salary
whose hours are taken up by dealing with
the litigation litigation has to go
through some stages for about a month or
so before you get to the rule 22
disclosure requirements by then you're
talking about who's our mediator going
to be what's the timelines for Discovery
um how many people are we going to be
talking about as Witnesses oh and by the
way what's the policy limit so a fair
amount of work has to get done to get to
a simple piece of information so it will
on occasion save a pie avoid a piece of
litigation that would otherwise be
unnecessary not a big deal but it's it's
a help in those cases where it becomes
important um and to be honest with you
it it
supports the very collegial atmosphere
that New Hampshire we love to brag about
and it's true how collegial the
atmosphere is between plaintiff's
lawyers the defense bar and the
insurance adjusters we deal with the
same lawyers and the same adjusters on
the other side all the time you know I I
have have had thousands of cases in my
career and I've probably dealt with 50
different adjusters and 20 or 30
different lawyers our reputations with
each other mean a lot so the
gamesmanship you hear about the reverse
engineering you hear about that we're
going to reverse engineer our
cases I don't do that I don't know
anybody who does I can't say that nobody
will do it but the people will going to
do it because of the disclosure
requirement they're going to file suit
and they're going to do it anyway you
know the fact that you tell them early
what I can tell you is one thing I've
had any number of situations where and
and not involving my cases where
insurance carriers are not often shy
about reaching out to Injured parties
they're insured contact s say I was in a
crash yesterday what I do what do I do
they get the information the information
includes who's the person who got hit
and before you know it the person who
got hit is getting a phone call or a
letter from the insurance company saying
we want to do right by you let's talk
and they make settlement
offers if they would to disclose the
policy limit and they could make it
instill make a settlement offer and get
a case settled that's great if they
don't disclose the limit then that
person comes to me and ask any insurance
agent any insurance industry
representative and they will they have
the statistics how much more do they pay
out on average on claims where people
are represented by lawyers than on
claims where people settle their own
cases with the adjusters so it's
actually to the insurance company's
benefit to disclose will in most cas
cases Will a smaller limit be disclosed
for the sake of getting the case over
with yes will there be cases where it's
not disclosed because I I'll call I'll
call
adjusters when a when a case comes to me
I'm not going to do all the research
research ahead time but if I already
know that the person's been in the
hospital for a month or they've got 20
or $30,000 worth of bills I'll call on a
J say hey Jim um I've already got
$20,000 in bills the guy's still
treating it's a pretty serious injury
can can you tell what kind of a policy
you got here because if this is going to
be a $25,000 settlement let's just do it
quicker it's it's easier and cheaper and
quicker for everybody and if they tell
me they do you know I obviously I got to
do my due diligence and see if there's
other policies and things like that but
almost all the time the cases end up
settling within the policy if you
know but if you don't know then you do
have to file the suit and those other
things happen um so I I'd like to think
that we have a very collegial atmosphere
here I do practice in other states where
it is a mandatory disclosure it's been
mandatory in Maine for 15 years and it's
been mandatory in Massachusetts
for almost as long as I've been
practicing maybe even since before us
practice I don't remember when it went
in what I can tell you is there's it's
never been an issue I mean it doesn't
cause any problems no no plaintiff's
lawyers act any differently on account
of knowing except we do reverse engineer
the value of our cases and our willing
to settle based on the policy limit in
one situation where the policy limit is
smaller than what we think the case is
worth we will almost always almost
always agree to take a policy limit
settlement rather than pursue personal
assets or something along those lines in
40 some odd years and thousands of cases
I've
seen it's either four or five cases and
not all of them mine I've seen four or
five cases in which the the lawyers you
know pursued assets or something beyond
the policy one of one or two of those
were mine and the others were colleagues
and partners and such so we do reverse
engineer in the sense of taking less
than the case is worth if we know the
policy is you know too small um as long
as we've done our due diligence to make
sure that you know we're not missing out
on another policy or something along
those lines um I could talk but I'd
rather just if there are any questions
I've heard intriguing questions I think
it's a very active panel here I think
that's great I'd love to if if if any of
the questions you've asked haven't been
answered to your satisfaction by others
I'd love to take a shot at them for you
other than that I will stop thank you
for
listening I think they're all set I
guess they're all set thank you much
thank you I got one card left Mike mofin
representing All
State and you're going to do three
minutes right Mike probably L all right
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Mike mcgl I'm a
lawyer and lobbyist in coner
representing allate Insurance I'll try
not to repeat what's been said before
but through my personal experience with
insurance I've had a few car accidents
and one of the most interesting things
is when the police come to the police
report they take your name they ask you
for your insurance card even though we
don't have mandatory Insurance New
Hampshire uh they do get the insurance
card I can talk to that personally
because it last 6 months in June I had a
card accident not my fault of course but
they did get the insurance card from me
so the uh people had the information
available right then and there the thing
that I find troubling about this bill is
how about a multiple car accident three
or four or five cars pile up by 93 you
have a b c d e f and g looking to does g
get H does f get a who gets what from
who the Dynamics of uh the New Hampshire
Insurance Market commented earlier on by
the the insurance department I agree
with that and people keep saying we're
the only one who doesn't have this we
the only one doesn't have that those are
the Dynamics in the inhabit Insurance
Market which keep our rates as low as
they are and in the automobile claim
world uh with the expensive cars as they
coming insurance premiums are getting
higher and higher so anything that
changes the marketplace should will
probably have a negative effect on
premiums the other part of the bill
which I think is kind of remarkable is
the restricting the information only to
automobiles I do not want to see it
broadened as it was in the Senate but
what's the difference between a broken
leg in a Chevy or a broken leg falling
on a faulty flight of stairs uh the
claim is a personal injury claim but if
it happens on all they want to get the
information um we don't see the need we
see the Dynamics in claims and
settlements as illustrated by the
insurance department be the back and
forth that keeps a claim uh reasonable
and Hampshire has been very good in um
reasonable recover recoveries just
recoveries for many many years so we
oppose the bill we like the system as it
is and we think it's working well thank
you thank you very much having no more
cards I will close the public
hearing on
423 and we are half an hour late good
bill because think how long that one
took us yesterday
Apprentice you ready okay we're ready
Senator
Apprentice we introduce her Bill thank
you very much uh good morning chair hunt
members of house Commerce and consumer
affairs longtime no see I am here to
introduce Senate Bill 556 as amended you
would
I trust you have the amended version um
this bill
prohibits Insurance reimbursements
solely based on uh participating
providers licensure so very briefly uh
when we originally introduced this it's
been based on a problem in New Hampshire
where we don't well actually problem
Nationwide but specifically this applies
to New Hampshire where we don't have
enough Primary Care Providers Primary
Care Providers services are are either
Physicians or nurse practitioners and
they I they serve as what I refer to as
like a traffic cop when you have a PCP
they see you they make decisions about
what referrals you may need for whatever
your complaint or condition is there's
some cases where you don't have to have
a referral but a lot of them a lot of
the medical conditions and Specialties
like just to get an MRI you've got to
have a referral um so over time what has
come to Bear is that we don't have
enough Physicians that are primary care
physicians so the nurse practitioners
who are independently licensed to
practice just like the Physicians have
been acting or working as pcps providing
the same services but not reimbursed the
same way um and just you know quickly
and it's not with any disrespect to The
Physician Community it's just this is a
nationwide problem uh my mother who is
now 92 and she doesn't like when I say
that moved to New Hampshire um two years
ago and could not get a primary care
physician and we live in you know like
the home of Health Care in New Hampshire
so she chose um to go with a nurse
practitioner and loves her nurse
practitioner so with that being said we
were initially seeking to bring parody
in payment for services provided the
same as Physicians the right now with
the acception of Anthem who does
reimburse for Primary Care and
Behavioral Health at 100% um Health
insurers were primarily following the
CMS guidance which is 80 the nurse
practitioners are reimbursed at 85% of
what the Physicians are um
so during discussions we initially had
passed it with parody um but it wouldn't
work uh based on all the different types
well all the different carriers um and
we were looking at amending the nurse
pract the nurse Practice Act versus
really and with the thanks of Heidi
croll and the the insurance providers
worked towards amending the statute
which is 420j which has to do with
provider contract standards instead to
try to incrementally get us to where I
think ultimately we need to be is for
same for same Services same pay but for
now the position is let's highlight this
and provide clarification in the
provider contract standards so Nerf
practitioners especially the ones that
are the leads for practices they can
actually point to this in the law and
negotiate with the different insurance
companies to get a better rate and
ultimately get the same as positions
which is 100% so that we introduced it
for parity we amended to bring Clarity
um I thank both the nurse practitioners
and the insurance carriers for getting
at the table and trying to find a
solution to this so we can you know do
better by our granted stators in terms
of uh primary care and um including you
know just general primary care and
Behavioral Health and and that's my
those are my opening remarks I'm happy
to take any questions you might
have representative
spear it's it says uh on line
four uh that reimbursement Provisions
licensure what do I do with solely I I I
can't figure out as someone trying to
evaluate
legislation what do I do with words
solely I I mean I don't know what to say
well thank you for your question but as
it is right now lure is used in
reimbursement for Primary Care and
behavioral F Health based as the
criteria by which reimbursement is made
so what I am asking and I again worked
with um the insurance carriers is to
change that so that when they are
negotiating they can't use that as the
primary decision maker clarification
please um so let's talk about the word
soy okay okay okay so um soy is a very
famous word in this committee room and
it goes back to that um when the bill
the bills the issue we've always had was
um uh auto insurance rates and that auto
insurance uh would sometimes use your
credit
report as to uh decide on what uh
they're going to make for you and offer
on insurance so we've had this
legislation we've had many time where
the issue came in what are we going to
do what are we going to do and there
came that word
solely because an insurance company when
it makes its reimbursements rates what
whatever it's going to reimburse it has
to have data behind it to why it uses
you know whatever criteria uses it has
to prove that that criteria is a
legitimate
criteria and so so the word solely um
was sense that that you were not going
to get your uh insurance rate simply
because you had a bad credit report
there had to be other things in there so
in this case it would be that they're
not going to solely reimburse because
it's a nurse practitioner they're going
to use other statistics such as U your
degrees or what what um how many years
you were
how many what's your all these other
things um I would say over the past
years um we used to have a big thing
about being board
certified and that Physicians had to be
board certified and that was a criteria
so uh over the years these issues of
what is an insurance company can use for
setting that rate now normally uh when
it comes to the uh primary care
physician the rate is really somewhat
set based upon where they are where the
market area is and what's the going you
know uh what it has been for other
primary care physicians but in this case
um you're saying it based upon your
practice so it's not just a primary care
in this case it's not just primary care
and nurse practitioners it can be
anything the way this is said solely is
that can be anything the health
insurance carrier when they're going to
reimburse and what they're whatever rate
they're going to agree to whatever
they're going to offer that's and this
is negotiated by the way
that they're going to have to show uh
that there is some uh statistical
history about why they got to the number
they got so that's where the word solely
comes from so you're saying it actually
has a real meaning because it seems to
me that just the way this is written
without anything in there it could be
because your hair is brown I mean
anything they would have to be able to
show statistically that someone who had
brown hair does it say something in here
about that having to that again
again they say this that's an inside you
know how insurance is done so yes this
this word this way this is written has
deep meaning terms of the department and
they will they'll come up and tell you
okay they will testify but it absolutely
has meaning and that is when you're
negotiating the rate they can't simply
say well that's you're a nurse
practitioner so we're going to pay you
less simply because you're a nurse
practitioner
represent thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chair um question
about uh leveling of costs right so if
you have different license types that
are getting reimbursed differently um
and and you have to ignore the insurance
company has to ignore uh the license
type uh where how do they level those
costs between you know different license
types that have different level of
training we do have someone from the
insurance department so I think they can
they can take that all right thank you
for the question we have someone from
the insurance department that's great
like okay any other questions for the
senator yes thanks for taking my
question um as uh the chair mentioned
that um you know they need to rely on
data to come to these conclusions and
I'm reading um frankly I I was
pleasantly surprised to see that a lot
of studies show that nurse practitioner
ERS and um Physicians provide the same
level of care so is that going to be
taken into account
in thank you for the question
representative burrow so we um they do
and that's the reason that we're here
but um initially we propose I propos
legislation that standards uh we we know
that an Anthem is already doing this
others are not but are open to the
conversation it's how to get that there
and it belongs in one the insurance
statute not the nurse practice act so as
a step to get this moving
forward the compromise was to use the
level of licensure um in the contract
negotiations by these nurse Le nurse
practitioner Le practices to have
something to point their finger to to
try to get a better rate and get closer
to the same level of rates that the
Physicians have that's that's the best
that we're at right now and it was a
brilliant compromise it was
proposed by others and agreed to uh by
the crew thank
you just uh represent Herbert has a
question yeah I wonder excuse
me my understanding my understanding is
that uh primary care physicians are
becoming rare yes and that the hospitals
are I don't know what they're doing with
them I I actually happen to really like
my primary care physician so and I'm not
knocking the uh what was the uh
difference um that you mentioned if
you're not a primary care who else is
doing it the nurse practitioners nurse
practitioner who were here Y and I uh
and I'm I'm not dissing that at all and
in fact the data in you know indicates
that they do a really good job but I'm
my question is do you
how do we uh preserve the primary care
physician because I think they're in in
uh difficulty so thank you uh for the
question representative Hebert uh I the
best way for me to answer that is that
we we're aware of the problem in New
Hampshire we're aware of the problem
nationally I'm going to point to the um
Office of the State Office of rural
Health which brings as funding from the
federal government and works to do uh
loan reimburse um student loan payback
programs to recruit you know specific
types of Physicians into the state um to
help that's just one example to help
alleviate this problem which is you know
really honestly at a crisis State U for
Primary Care so there have been and
that's probably the example I can point
to most quickly as a strategy to address
this so I love my primary care provider
shout out to Debbie Glazer she's
wonderful but I know she's a rare okay
thank you okay thank you very
much have to you know got shout out my
mother my daughter my primary care
thanks for represent hun committee right
it's not the Oscars here okay uh
Michelle
Heaton hello Michelle Heaton I'm the
director of Life and Health at the New
I guess I'll start off by answering some
of the questions the way this kind of
started out was under CMS guidelines for
Medicare reimbursement they allow a step
down in reimbursement rates for aprns
and PAs and this is Nationwide and it's
good to note that Across the Nation the
scope of practice for aprns is different
in New Hampshire we have a very broad
scope of practice and the APRN can
practice independently and they can
prescribe so in that respect they are on
the same level as doctors um so under
the
Medicare system there is a set rate and
that is the 100% rate that the doctor
would
get the CMS system allows an APRN to
have a reduced amount of 85% of that
rate it is not mandatory it is allowed
so I think this this is what this bill
was intended to do is that assuming all
things are level in provider
reimbursement you can't just knock them
down to 85% of what you would have paid
them just because they are an APRN so
that's the issue that we're trying to
fix here um in this state yes there's
work short for Workforce shortages for
um healthc care providers you know all
over the place for that reason that is
why the market has required aprns to be
reimbursed in new Hamp at a higher rate
and that's why I believe Anthem
reimburses them um on par with doctors
because they understand we need Primary
Care Providers and we're going to have
to pay them more when we're talking
about provider reimbursement there
are it's rare that two doctors are going
to make the same amount there's a number
of factors that go into their
contractual negotiations between the
health carrier and the provider and
those can include um the geographic area
they're in the type of practice they
have how many patients under you know a
carrier's plan go to that practice how
their expertise um how long they've been
practicing you know do they have
enhanced certifications all of those
factors go into contractual negotiations
and setting the reimbursement rates what
this bill would do is make it so
assuming all of those other factors are
even you can't reimburse aprns or PAs or
any other license sh at a lower level
than at a the level for a doctor so I'm
happy to take any questions I hope that
clarifies um that help you out
representa
spear yeah I I think I got it great okay
thank you very much that was perfect
okay uh what should I do next um okay so
I'm going to call on yeah because I have
no idea what she's going to say so
Margaret Donovan from DMC Primary
Care you didn't check off whatever you
so good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee um my name is Margaret
dunavan I'm a doctorally prepared family
nurse practitioner I'm also The Clinical
Director at DMC Primary
Care um I have worked as a nurse
practitioner in family practice for the
past eight years years in my role as a
nurse practitioner I provide Primary
Care to a panel of my own patients
across the lifespan in the greater Dairy
area my patients view me as their
primary care provider and are confident
in the care that I that they
receive the greatest joy of this work is
to see patients through the many highs
and lows of life always focusing on
disease prevention and health promotion
as a nurse first I feel uniquely able to
provide patient centered care I'm proud
to work alongside an incredible team of
Physicians nurse practitioners and
physician assistance at DMC primary care
I value the experience and knowledge
base that all of my team members bring
in all we serve 880,000 plus patients in
Southern New Hampshire and have clinics
across seven
communities we have advanced practice
providers that have been with our
Organization for over two decades all of
our providers do the same work we all
treat and manage acute and chronic
conditions in all of our patients our
Clinic days contain the same appointment
types complexity and
responsibilities as I say to our
providers that are new to our
organization it's often hard to remember
who has what credentials behind their
name our practice hired and onboarded 12
advanced practice providers in 2023
alone with an 100% retention rate
our AP recruitment has fostered our
organizational ability to continue to
accept new patients and to keep an open
access model for the past several years
DMC primary care has admitted over
10,000 new patients to our practice
every year our patients are able to be
seen same day often within hours this
keeps the cost of overall health care
down by keeping patients from seeking
unnecessary emergency care
well outside of our offices It is Well
documented that nurse practitioners are
essential to enhancing patient access
particularly for Rural underserved and
vulnerable
populations multiple Studies have
consistently demonstrated that advanced
practice providers give highquality cost
efficient Health Care the state of New
Hampshire has recognize this by allowing
nurse practitioners to practice
independently free of physician
supervision for many
years nurse practitioners practice
autonomously assessing patients
performing supervising and interpreting
Diagnostic and laboratory tests making
diagnosis initiating and managing
treatment coordinating care and
counseling educating counseling and
educating patients and their
families for all these reasons I urge
you to support that nurse practitioners
be provided equal reimburse M for
performing the same service as our
physician colleagues closing the
reimbursement Gap is essential to ensure
that all patients have access to
highquality health care I'm confident
that this will have a positive impact on
the overall Healthcare landscape in the
granite state the the status quo just
won't do thank
you thank you uh I think we're all set
thank you very much uh chair will call
croll good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee um for the record my
name is Heidi croll um I work at
Gallagher cahan and gartrell and I
represent ahip which is America's health
insurance plans um I'd say at this point
we're neutral on the bill is um you've
heard from um Senator um Apprentice um
we did oppose s SP 558 as introduced um
and also some earlier draft amendments
to the
bill um so we did uh oppose the payment
parody mandate um where all nurse
practitioners would um kind of
automatically be paid the same as
Physicians um we objected to that fact
um to to that for a number of reasons
one um that a payment parody mandate
would be government intervention or
interference um into private contract
negotiations between the two um private
entities um as you know and as you've
heard and discussed reimbursement rates
are negotiated um between providers and
insurers and there's no really one
formula um or set reimbursement rate for
a provider regardless of what type of
Provider you're talking about um for the
more earlier versions of sp sp 556 um
really would have been um unworkable um
because there there is no single
reimbursement rate for Physicians so it
was kind of like what parody with what
um so uh and as you heard it would have
Tim been going into the um nurse
practitioner statutes which just would
have been problematic from a perspective
of carriers need to be confident that
when they are looking at the insurance
statutes that those are the laws that
they need to be um complying with um so
with all of that said ahip did have a
number of discussions with um Senator
Apprentice um the bill spye sponsor and
Advocates and ultimately offered um the
language that is before you today um
that we thought could um you know offer
a reasonable alternative path forward so
that's that's what I perfect thank you
thank
you all right so I have no opposition to
the bill I can say that to all you about
to I'm going to call up uh you're all
about three minutes and uh I I used to
I'm supposed to say please don't repeat
with someone else's already said which
might not be leave you with a lot to say
but uh we do want to hear from you all
Ohan yeah thank H there you go good
morning and thank you for your time I
will keep my remarks quite short I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
nurse practitioner Association I'm
joined today by several of my colleagues
I wanted to point out a couple of things
there's been references this morning to
primary care physicians
that is a that is an accurate term
however I want to be clear when you're
selecting a PCP it when you as a when
you are when when you purchase your
insurance and you select your PCP you
are selecting a primary care provider
which all of the commercial insurers in
New Hampshire agree that a nurse
practitioner is equal in being able to
to be that person as as as your
physician so um representative Herbert
you you mentioned that you have a
primary care physician that that you
really enjoy but you're concern about um
how are we going to make sure that
everybody has the ability to have a PCP
well we do that by making sure that
everybody can afford to stay in business
and part of how we do that is we make
sure that they are reimbursed for the
services that they provide at a rate
that Mak sense and it's fair I will say
that New Hampshire Medicaid has
recognized this for a long time there's
been parody nurse practitioners and
Physicians are paid equally for the
services that they provide by New
Hampshire Medicaid we do have data that
will show um we we we've seen in some of
the insurers policies that they clearly
state that they will pay nurse
practitioners at the 85% following
Medicare so we know what happening in
New Hampshire we also have data analysis
done by the all claims database which is
um which clearly shows we we've looked
at it um a a group has looked at it and
they've looked at the
99214 um billing code which which is a
pretty General visit and they've laid
out all of the uh primary care physician
or primary care provider Primary Care
practices in New Hampshire so all across
the state they've looked out physician
Le nurse practitioner Le and combined
and we and then they've looked at all
the commercial insurers put them all in
a column and then they sort them and
clear as day all of the nurse
practitioner owned and led practices
fall at the bottom third so when we talk
about how we make sure that we keep
those PC PS we got to make sure that
they're not vulnerable just because they
have a different license to that gets
them to be able to do the same exact
service so I'm going to leave it to my
good morning chairman and members of
this
committee I'm Nancy Wilson a former
nurse practitioner I was employed by
conquered family medicine for over 10
years I'll make this short because um
most of this has been covered already
but I am today testifying in support of
I'm sorry no no you had it on you just
need to do closer you you need to turn
it back on and then keep it Clos um
right so you you notice how close I keep
mine to me yeah I do all right thank you
um I'm as I said I'm testifying in
support of SB uh
556 uh which addresses payment parody to
New Hampshire nurse practitioners um we
uh do enjoy a a broad uh scope of
practice uh which has been established
for years here in New Hampshire uh it's
really important to know um that each
state actually has their own scope SC of
practice um not ideal but uh here in New
Hampshire uh we are actually able to
practice
autonomously um and uh therefore assume
the same liability risks uh as physician
practices same overhead uh and because
in New Hampshire particularly uh small
businesses seem to be the backbone of
this state uh it's important for nurse
practitioner to be able to um realize uh
the benefits of opening their own
practice and I would like to support
this bill would support that thank you
great thank you very
much if you have written testimony you
can certainly submit it to the clerk we
abot am I the last no
no all right I will talk quick thank you
very much for inviting me to speak here
my name is Peggy Abbott I'm a
psychiatric nurse
practitioner I work in a treatment
center and I help people who deal with
mental illness as well as their
addictions New Hampshire needs more
psychiatric providers in the community
to help these people maintain sobriety
while taking care of their mental health
many psych providers have long weight
lists
I know of several psych nurse
practitioners that take cash paying
clients because the reimbursement rates
from the insurance companies isn't
sustainable to support overhead and
living expenses the ones who do take
insurance have incredibly long weight
list for clients to be seen and it's
very defeating for someone to beat
addiction and get mental health
treatment while in recovery but they
can't have support once they're in the
community I also have have a private
practice and take insurance including
Medicaid the number of inquiries for new
appointments has been overwhelming and
the most of the calls are from people
who have Medicaid saying they've been
calling around for months trying to get
treatment for their mental health I got
credentialed with Medicaid because I was
sad hearing the size from people on the
other end of the phone when I had told
them that I wasn't they'd beg me to help
find them somebody who could see them
stating nobody takes my
insurance Medicaid is known for its
lower reimbursement rate the patients
are usually the sickest so we want to
help them with the low reimbursement
rates from our commercial insurers it's
difficult and we use that balance to
make ends
meet it's clearly stated in the
insurance contracts that our physician
colleagues can get 15% more
reimbursement than we do for the same
services to similar patients how is this
failed
patients appreciate nurse practitioners
and seek the quality of treatment we
provide we are first trained as nurses
and have the holistic approach that
patients like and Trust we are not less
than our physician colleagues we are
simply another Choice our care should
not be
discounted there's a constant growing
need for psychiatric providers in New
Hampshire dual diagnosis is rampant in
our state a quality reimbursement for
the vital services we provide would show
our worth within the insurance company
the citizens of New Hampshire who pay
out of pocket for treatment because the
insurance rate reimbursement rate is so
low would appreciate it especially when
coverage thank you okay so I just want
to make sure I understand because did
you say Medicaid does pay a difference
or does is doesn't pay a difference
parody I thought you just said that
there was a 15 Medicaid there was a 15%
difference no okay all right I
misunderstood what you said no it's just
Medicaid reimbursement can be a little
bit lower than the insurance companies
that we know that Medicaid is the lowest
of all possible reimbursements so we use
the commercial insurance is to balance
out Medicaid okay great uh we do have a
question thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry
I probably should have asked this sooner
but can you and if not you then maybe
someone else can answer what's the
difference between a physician's
assistant and a nurse practitioner and
the level of training versus a
physician's level of training okay
that's a great question so nurse
practitioners are nurses so we've gotten
uh training as a nurse whether it's it's
probably registered nurse with a
bachelor's degree and then we have extra
training as a at a master's level and we
are board certified in our
Specialties Physicians assistants are um
they have a bachelor's degree and then
they get two years more of training in
the medical
environment and did you ask about
Physicians yeah yeah I mean Physicians
get seven to eight years of college
training and and exper residency and
correct okay yeah so follow for question
me inquire thank you so is this bill
just for nurse practitioners it's for
Physicians assistants as well just for
nurse practitioners okay thank you
it unless it's in yeah no like it says
healthc care car not established payment
reimburse based solely on the provids
lure so it it would be all all
okay okay thank you very much see the
things we learn in public hearings isn't
it good why we have these hearings okay
uh Faith
CFT 85% of phans
MDS what's that oh wrong wrong uh 8
versus 6 okay all uh Ryan do I have the
right one okay Ryan uh
[Music]
aqualia good morning it's aqualina
aqualina night's
try all right so I understand that this
bill is geared toward primary care but
it also affects me as a licensed
clinical mental health counselor um so
first I wanted to thank you for even
considering this bill um um because
reimbursement parody among licensed
clinical Mental Health Counselors and
licensed social workers has been a fight
that I've been having since I opened my
practice in
2021 um the reimbursement practices for
Behavioral Health are discriminatory at
just about every insurance company um
and I'll say that I worked for a
psychological practice before I hung my
own shingle and I took a 30% cut from
not working under a psychologist
um and practicing
independently um
so I run bod Counseling Services which
is a 27 clinician practice and it has a
state rde reach and is currently serving
over 1,00 active clients pay equity for
Mental Health Counselors has been a
Forefront issue since we opened and not
a day has gone by that either my I or my
administrative staff haven't fought with
insurance companies to get paid fairly
for the work we're doing I also had to
recently make the difficult decision to
not take Medicare at my practice and it
was because of this
issue uh the inequitable reimbursement
practices because social workers and
licensed clinical Mental Health
Counselors do the same work but they're
reimbursed
differently and I'm going to give you
sort of the cliff not Cliffs notes
version of my written testimony because
there's a there's a pretty specific
story about um an issue that I have with
New Hampshire Medicaid but my primary
question actually that I'm coming to you
with is would this bill also cover
Medicaid
no no okay I would ask that you consider
that a cover Medicaid if it's possible
um because Private Practice licensed
clinical Mental Health Counselors make
80% of what they do in Community Mental
Health Centers and so it's because of so
if you look at the fee schedule which is
public information licensed clinical
Mental Health Counselors the rate is 80%
of the same service in the same billing
code um it and so we just had a pretty
big rate increase for Medicaid back in
January which I'm very very thankful for
so thank you for your work on that
whatever your role in that was but the
margin is still unacceptable so be so
before the rate increase we were paid
67% of what Community Mental Health
Centers were paid and if Community
Mental Health Centers didn't have such
long waiting lists and those clients
were not coming through our doors I
probably wouldn't be making such hay out
of this issue but
there's at least one Community Mental
Health Center that doesn't even have
clinicians and isn't keeping a waiting
list and so they come to us and so we're
serving higher and higher Acuity clients
for much lower wages and this is across
the board Medicaid just happens to be
the most glaring issue but it's
happening across the board with all
insurance companies um
so I appreciate your
time I gave you my written testimony but
I'm going to give you the cliffs note
like I just wanted to make it brief no
great thank you very much all right one
card left Sabrina dunand from antrum and
now I know what you wrote there I think
you meant to say neutral but you forgot
the T sorry about that so very messy
handwriting well thank you anyway um yes
neutral um Sabrina Dunlap director of
government relations for Anthem and
appreciate um Senator apprentice and
other stakeholders looping us all in
early and this was a collaborative
process
I just wanted to point out one thing to
the earlier issue that came up
um uh hoping that we can change provider
to specify that it is limited to aprns I
would defer to the nurse practitioners
as to what exactly the the correct
phrases I don't know if it's NP I think
it's APRN um but just to clarify because
otherwise that becomes a relatively
broad Amendment to the existing
statute I think we just discussed that
by the person who testified before I so
wondering whether it's going to cover a
mental health provider well I think
aprn's probably broad enough to cover
medical and and mental health but um
this provider would apply conceivably to
every provider so so hoping to limit it
to just nurse practitioners okay well
make note of
that I did just chat with Susan pasel I
think they're okay with that because
that was our Collective understanding
okay all right thank you all right uh
having no more cards I will close the
public
hearings
not 558 another Insurance these are all
all
least this will be our last Senate
bill of the session of this session we
we'll have heard everything and then
we'll spend the next two weeks well I
think you'll enjoy this hearing so much
that I think there's a little bit of
okay so open up the public hearing on
Senate Bill 558
and you don't look like
represent
okay did you fill out a pin card I did
okay so it might be in but go ahead okay
far away good morning Mr chairman and
members of the House Commerce and
consumer affairs committee uh for the
record I am Senator Rebecca Perkins
quoka from Senate District 21 the city
of Portsmouth and the towns of Durham
Lee Madbury Newcastle newfields
Newington and New Market I'm here today
to introduce SB 558 an act relative to
insurance coverage for infertility
treatments protection from
discrimination during IVF treatments
parental leave and adoption we all want
to see New Hampshire
Thrive our job as policy makers is to
set up a system where we can step aside
and let our residents P pursue their
lives and Empower them to achieve their
dreams
what it means to build a family in New
Hampshire will always evolve and today
I'm here to address pieces of that as a
representative of my generation and also
our sorely needed Workforce I believe
additional pieces around family building
are necessary to maintain our
competitiveness and attract and retain
the workforce we need for the state we
all love to continue to grow and Thrive
for
Generations workers as patients are
looking and comparing their lives in
various places and the protections of
available there around building a family
and it is increasingly a core piece of
where people choose to live and build
their lives in families I talk to every
day the families that make up this
Workforce and the core of our economy
these concerns are at the Forefront of
their lives especially women who
contribute so much to our state but
frequently both parents experience much
anxiety about whether they can get
pregnant balance their jobs talk to
their employer leave for doctor's
deployment and demonstrate their
commitment to their work all while
trying to accomplish the goal of
building a family housing and other
Rising costs simply required that many
times both parents be at work these are
people we want to support they are
people we say we value but we need to
demonstrate that value through some
simple pieces this bill asks to expand
diagnostic insurance coverage for
same-sex couples and expands our
pregnancy
discrimination statute to Encompass the
real situations our constituents deal
with with these are highly personal
matters one might argue that in today's
employment Market employees have a lot
of negotiating power to address these
issues with their
employers and yet we see that even today
even in that employment Market these
issues are not being addressed our
residents are still hard workers they're
still professionals negotiating parental
benefits and accommodations can feel
like talking to your employer about time
away from your job when in fact you are
giving the our residen these simple
pieces will be small and continuing to
build modern economy for our state that
modern economy recognizes that workers
need different support than we needed 30
or 40 years ago if this feels novel just
talk to any employer out there they will
tell you the workforce and healthc Care
standards have changed and that our job
is to support the economy and these
workers so that our small businesses can
find what they need to continue to
function
the amendment the version of the bill is
amended by the Senate represents
countless hours of work VI very many
invested stakeholders including
practitioners attorneys the New
Hampshire insurance department insurance
carriers and legislators the Senate has
slimmed down the bill to its core
essential functions ensuring coverage
for the diagnostic pieces required for
samesex couples and protecting employees
from discrimination for simple leave I
hope you have all seen the updated
fiscal note as amended which is a
attached to the bill and it states a
very reasonable cost for these small
pieces that can bring very large
economic benefits to our state with that
I'm happy to take any questions thank
chairman uh any questions to the
committee members see guess it's pretty
straightforward Bill all right thank you
chairman um I would be grateful if you
would call Katherine Tucker next just
because she uh okay normally we we call
the insurance department but if you want
me to oh okay you were the chair but um
just wanted to put that forward you want
her next thank you okay all
right uh since the insurance department
is busy working on this issue that I
just asked him to do we'll call up
Katherine
Tucker and I hope you're not going to
take 10
turn turn your mic turn you have to put
the mic on there you
go
I'm red is good is good okay thank you
my name is Katherine Tucker I live in
lonia and I am also an attorney that
practices out of Lowden and I just folks
I picked up a copy of the bill off the
table and it had the wrong fiscal note
attached so I just want to make sure
everybody's working off the right
phisical note because there is you know
tremendous difference the one that I is
418 so this bill has two pieces the
first piece is the insurance piece and
what this piece does is it provides
coverage for people in New Hampshire in
large group plant to have intrauterine
insemination procedures done IUI is a
procedure where sperm is placed into the
uterus with the goal that the sperm
makes its way to where it needs to be to
the egg and and everything happens so
forth this has a much higher success
rate than putting the sperm in the
vagina because the sperm is much closer
to where it eventually needs to go so
this procedure is is a very low Tech
small procedure that is a tiny piece out
of what the cost study looked at last
year you remember we talked about a cost
Study last year that was extremely broad
this is one tiny low Tech piece of that
this procedure because it requires a
uterus is only going to help those
people who have a uterus so specifically
the groups that are going to be helped
are female couples and single women who
have not only a uterus but who have a
fallopian tube and an ovary in order to
make this work intrauterine insemination
IUI is the firstline medical treatment
for these two groups of people bottom
line is these people need help they need
medical help to get pregnant and they
need donor sperm and the donor sperm has
to find its way to the egg so the piece
of getting donor sperm is not covered we
are not asking the insurers to pay for
any of that a lot of that can include
non-medical costs that is not that
nothing is changing with that th that's
going to be out of pocket self-pay all
the time what we're asking for payment
for is the placement of that sperm into
somebody's uterus and that is a low Tech
medical procedure it doesn't involve IVF
it doesn't involve surrogacy none of
those expensive things egg retrievals
any of that stuff is not involved it's a
very low Tech simple procedure and it's
a procedure that is recognized by the uh
American Society for Reproductive
Medicine as medically necessary for
these folks I'll pass around um
something in a moment but what the what
happened in 2023 is that the American
Society for Reproductive Medicine
changed its medical guidelines and said
you know what infertility does include
those folks that need medical
intervention including but not limited
to the use use of donor gamits in order
to achieve a successful pregnancy either
as an individual or a partner so we now
are in a position where the leading
medical Authority considers this
treatment medically necessary for female
couples and single women and the reason
that we're saying six Cycles is because
that's the medically defined limit
that's what that's what doctors are
going to recommend six cycles of intun
and insemination if you're not pregnant
at the end of six we need to rethink
things and and see if there's a problem
going on here like I said it's very low
Tech it's inexpensive it's something
that can be done by a doctor a nurse a
nurse practitioner a phys physicians
assistant it's not something that people
are doing at home though um and I just
wanted to address address a
misconception that I had heard I had
heard that this bill might help male
couples too because it it gives them the
option to have an insemination done on
their surrogate and I just want to say
that that to inseminate your surrogate
that's traditional surrogacy we don't
like that we don't favor that at all not
in our law or our practice there it's
not illegal but it's essentially a
co-parenting arrangement with your
surgant so there's no doctor or or
lawyer that's ever going to recommend
that as a good thing so this is a bill
that helps specifically single women and
female couples and right now these are
folks that are paying out of pocket for
that medical treatment so not only do
they have all these expenses from
getting the sperm that they have to pay
out of pocket they also have to pay for
this intrauterine insemination procedure
out of pocket when their colleagues who
need that same procedure their straight
partnered colleagues don't have to pay
for that procedure so it it just it
makes sense to have this um this
particular piece covered now the second
part of the bill talks about employment
leave and I just want to mention that
when a person is going through fertility
treatments particularly the female
partner there's going to be a whole lot
of appointments most of these
appointments are routine quick in and
out for example an intrauterine
insemination you get go to the doctor 15
minutes you go home you go back to work
um there's occasionally a longer
appointment um such as for an embryo
transfer or if a person needs to have
surgery but primarily these appointments
are quick in and out and doctors will
schedule them during the lunch hour or
during early morning hours to help
work so how much does it cost I
understand that it's a 5 cents no no
that's that's that's not the number I'm
interested in how much how much are
these people who are doing it now out of
pocket how much are they spending
thousands of dollars and I've got some
folks here that are going to test
thousands of dollars yes then how can it
only be 144 for the whole state because
we are not Co there's no coverage for
the part of getting the sperm the only
coverage will be for placing the sperm
into the uterus so the thousands of
dollars includes getting the sperm yes
so what this covers how much does this
cost a few hundred a few
hundred I believe the insurance
department has those numbers they don't
have that's why I went over there she
has it
now so that's what I went over to ask
okay so so it's it that's that the
actual the getting the sperm can be very
expensive that's still the person still
has to pay for that yes you you won't be
back for that bill next year
no we got YouTube
now not next year oh well excuse me
you'll never be back for
that for for the stuff that has to do
with the sperm bank and the compensation
to the donor the travel costs for the
donor the legal cost for the donor no
I'm not going to ask for that in the
future okay okay so uh represent Ammon
has a question thank you Mr chair thank
you for your testimony and your
explanation I just want to make sure I I
understand the two parts of the bill so
the first part is the interuterine
insemination and that's a very specific
procedure that insurance would have to
cover yes the second part has to do with
leave and the leave the reasons for the
leave could are much broader right it's
not just for that procedure yes it could
also be for any other infertility
treatment yes that's correct and and
just a followup for the question M
inquire So reading the fiscal note it
talks about uh it's potentially it could
potentially add a burden on
municipalities and counties because they
have uh employment contracts that are
already existing and they may not have
very many employees uh so they couldn't
afford to lose one for a couple of weeks
um is that your understanding that uh
this could potentially be a mandate on
municipalities uh and their Workforce
yes but a couple of weeks that would be
a highly unusual situation that would be
a significant surgery just like any
other surgery if we're talking about the
treatment the normal the standard
treatments th those are not going to be
two week long procedures it's going to
be a one-day office visit you're back to
work the very next day yeah so why do we
have all the stuff in here then why is
why is that here if it's just a it's
just an office visit why I cuz this I
when I was reading I was thinking it was
lifting from our statute and that which
is that an employer can't fire of
someone who's out on on pregnancy leave
yes okay so is that what this is trying
to recreate here because that wouldn't
wouldn't matter that statue doesn't ask
how you got pregnant it clarify that
we're not including just that when
you're actually Pregnant part but the
trying to get pregnant right but you
just said it's an it's an office of
visit yes one day office
visit but so you go to work in the
morning you go to your office visit at
lunch and then you go back to work would
be a quick office visit a longer office
visit is you take the whole day off from
work again I if that's just one day why
we have all this in here what why do we
need to put all that in here well we
want to make sure that people are
protected when they take that one day
off or take that off that they could get
fired for that one day we want to make
sure that doesn't happen
okay all
Pier the the actual
procedure of inserting the sperm which
is what we're covering which is what
we're talking about but usually these
procedures usually uh there's there's
talks about medication there's talks
about doctors monitoring blood and all
this other kind of stuff we're not
talking about adding any of that
uh I I think that that would be a
case-by case decision made by The
Physician as to whether that person
needs medication now in terms of
monitoring yes you do have to put the
sperm into the uterus at the right point
in the woman's cycle so there's a lot of
inexpensive monitoring um supplies
things that can be done at home that
people would just buy over the counter
and monitor themselves at home and then
go into the office when their uh test
kits are indicating they need to be
inseminated
aren't you discriminating against gay
bill
um yes but this is a step in the right
direction and I think it's a very
important step female couples are in
this unique position of they can get
pregnant but they got to spend a whole
lot of money out of pocket in order to
make that happen if we can protect this
segment of of individuals I think that
is a giant step in the right direction I
know David Crosby is not alive anymore
but I've heard of someone just goes get
gets a guy and helps them out with that
anything I'm not following what you're
say I'm sorry I don't know Mr you don't
it it's
testimony you have a question for her do
you take one more question I'm sorry
would you take another question okay
represent M thank you Mr chairman
chart why should the try it
home be 12 months and not six months um
so when you're trying at home what you
you're doing is you're placing sperm
into the vagina whether you're doing it
through sexual activity or whether
you're using a syringe and putting the
sperm into the vagina it goes into the
vagina right by the cervix and then the
sperm has to make its way all the way
through the cervix and into the uterus
and up the Fallopian tubes so there's a
lot more that the sperm has got to do on
its own and therefore the success rates
are a lot lower we're talking probably
5% success rate per month versus 15 to
uterus swim swim swim okay but shouldn't
it be six months the same as six
rounds as far
as as far as how long the waiting period
is for both for both columns both both
situations both living or life
situations so if you're putting so it's
there so there's parity yep so if you
put the sperm into the vagina no I got
all that part I got that part I don't
think any of us need that lesson I hope
not both columns right both both types
of living situations here one six rounds
assuming that's one round a month versus
six months before that insurance
coverage K kicks in shouldn't there be
shouldn't it both both time periods be
six months that's all I'm asking that's
intentionally set at different time
frames and the reason because when the
lower success rate with the intra
vaginal or intracervical insemination is
means that you try more times before you
say this isn't working versus if you put
the sperm into the uterus you only have
to try six times before you can assess
whether this is not working so there's
medically defined different standards
and we're looking at the what the
doctors say if the procedure you're
doing is an IUI 6 months is the
medically appropriate time to try that
before we say hey wait a second here
there might be something else wrong that
we need to examine so if we wanted to
pick if we wanted to make give parody on
the timeline we could either change that
to six months or we could make
this three rounds or six months or six
rounds or 12 months whichever is greater
or something like that if we want to do
establish parity and timing based on the
medical evidence if you wanted to do
that this will be in the subcommittee
and just one comment if I could there is
a 12month ICI on the leftand
side that's current talking what the
bill
yeah okay thank you very much chair we
call on Michelle Heaton from the New
hello Michelle Heaton I'm the director
of life and health with the New
Hampshire insurance department um just
level set we are neutral on this bill we
are not taking a position it is a policy
decision for the policy makers to make
what benefits you want to mandate to
give a little background we do already
have a fertility mandate for the large
group market and that covers all
medically necessary fertility treatment
what this new mandate would do is
outside of what is medically
necessary and it would require that
insurers cover up to six rounds of IUI
um in a plan
year and to get to your questions
representative hunt um last year in our
claims data we observed 499 distinct
claims for this specific procedure the
we um assumed in the calculations of our
fiscal note which we had the whole
worksheet filled out and OLS condensed
it down so a lot of that got cut out um
but we assumed an upper limit of an
increase in claims of a
1,125
claims um so that would be a little bit
more than double the number of claims
right now to give a little bit more
background there was a bill about um
expanding access to f Services last
session that we did a mandate study on
over the summer that was a much broader
mandate study and some of our
assumptions are based on some of the
stuff in that report but this is a very
much more narrow um mandate so it's
essentially requiring that insurers
cover six rounds of the IUI procedure it
does not mandate coverage of any
medications or testing that may be
necessary or appropriate um for this
procedure I'm happy to answer any
much y oh do have questions oh all right
representative walls first and then
representative
spear thank you Mr chairman uh I'm just
looking at the verbiage in this bill uh
does the insurance industry see a
difference between IVF and
IUI because it I see that's both are
stated like an act it says during IVF
treatments should it be amended to say
fertility um treatments oh are you
looking at the description above yeah
the description right um I think that's
so this bill has been amended we have
been working on this for several months
so I think that may have been the
initial intent of the bill what the
language is that was landed on was just
IUI so I'm not a doctor but I know a
little bit based on this bill and IUI is
a specific procedure that was just being
described to us IVF is um just asking
insurance coverage wise I'm not asking
for the det okay so I already know the
details currently under insurance
coverage if you have a diagnosis of
infertility all of the different array
of services that may be necessary are
covered okay what this does is it
provides it makes this specific service
available without having to have that
diagnosis of
you thank you very much oh there
represent spear yes
sorry
I we just were handed a definition of
infertility and you had made the comment
that uh there's a it doesn't have a
medical necessity but based on the
definition we were just handed it is a
medical
necessity so did you hand this out I did
not I believe that is a policy statement
from an uh specific group I would not
consider that to be the accepted medical
necessity and that is not in line with
the way our statutes dep we have a
definition someplace in yes we do can we
see it can you tell us yeah we in the
old days we used to be fighting over the
language for every session where do we
find it in20 J three the definition sry
would you go go a little slower 420j
that's the magic that's the magic R1 J
4202020 colon 3 is the definition
section for Managed Care thank you and I
don't know exactly the Roman numeral but
there medical that'll keep you busy all
chapter but when that list where I send
out all the mandates they're all for2 Js
oh
okay okay this specific one is its own
chapter though specific to fertility the
fertility is a separate but 420j is
where you want to where you want to stop
shopping okay thank you very
good afternoon good afternoon uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Heidi croll I
work at Gallagher cahan and Grell and
I'm here today representing ahip
America's health insurance plans
um before I forget to mention it I will
also say that there is um the medically
necessary um language is also reflected
um and this was a deliberate decision
that we made when we were working with
the stakeholders a number of years years
ago when we put the fertility statute on
the books you know as a brand new
statute so it is also in
dasg colon um one under the definition
sections uh it's it's uh Roman six under
the definitions um you'll find that the
same definition of medically necess
Neary um we put that there as well so
um so first I just wanted to say that we
truly appreciate um the time and the
willingness of the Prime sponsor and The
Advocates the insurance department and
other legislators and Senate staff uh
everyone um put a lot of um time and
effort into this bill uh so it's been a
very good um stakeholder process lots of
meetings and phone calls and many many
drafts um so the communication around
this bill was very good um and we really
appreciate apprciate that um the issues
around this bill are complicated as you
may recall from um looking at similar
legislation last year um including how
to balance um compliance with medical
necessity law um our anti-discrimination
laws and then of course the cost impacts
of of this mandate or really any new
mandate um we do appreciate that the
bill has been substantially narrowed
from its as introduced version um we do
think it's a better structure uh
compared to the prior drafts um that the
stakeholders were considering um and is
certainly more straightforward and um
certainly easier to understand what the
new mandate would be um as you might
imagine we do still remain concerned uh
you know about language that talks about
coverage you know regardless of whether
or not the individual has a diagnosis of
infertility um so this is really getting
at the heart of medical necessity as you
know is a Cornerstone of Managed Care um
it ensures that um people are getting
appro quality care and that we're
watching out for um the costs that are
being borne by the premium payers and by
the patients themselves um so this
language you know obviously circumvents
medical necessity and that's just always
going to be a concern um for for the
carriers um and it's concerning really
because it opens the door um to
potential future mandates that also
might seek an exemption for medical
necessity and of course that could
really be a slippery slope and and a a
costly one as well
um as you know the costs of new mandates
are always a concern for us um I am
aware that the Bill's fiscal note
estimates the cost at 5 cents um per
member per month so that is certainly
lower um than some of the estimates that
were associated with prior drafts um so
that reduction is is very good to see
um uh however you know obviously this is
a brand new mandate um both here in New
Hampshire and really across the country
um as um the prior speaker was
mentioning there was a change at the um
by this Association back in late fall
October or November so you know it's
really just been in the last six months
or so that a handful of states are
moving in this direction um and so you
know part of what carriers are grappling
with is that there's not really um a
good handle anywhere um we can't really
look to other states to get a good
handle and what the actual cost will be
or how they might grow over time um and
of course this is one probably a number
of mandates that will pass or might
might pass um this session so we just
we're always cognizant of the fact that
um these things do add up um and of
course costs go up over time so um with
that I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions I did want to mention and I'm
sorry that this did not come to my
attention um earlier when this bill was
in the Senate um but the effective date
is um 60 days after passage um I
don't have any position on the second
part of the bill um around the
employment piece so I don't know what
makes sense for an effective date there
but um at least for the the Mandate the
insurance mandate portion of the bill if
the um if you are inclined to move
forward this we would respectfully
request a an effective date of January
1st of 2025 so my apologies for not
picking that up um when this bill was in
the
Senate okay any questions from the
committee members see none oh we do have
a question representative pelli thank
you quick question so what segment what
insurance segment would this pertain to
if we look at the pie chart sure yes
thank you for the question so this um
our current law around fertility
treatments and this one would be
consistent with it only targets the um
employer fully insured Market um so my
recollection is that that number
somewhere around 21% of the market so it
doesn't Target the individual market
fully insured um and it doesn't target
self-funded market or Medicaid or
Medicare or any of those other forms of
coverage so it's um exclusively employer
sponsored fully insured market and yeah
number okay thank you thank you all
right I have uh
four more cards here everybody's in
support so all I can say is please don't
repeat what the last person said and
craft hello my name is Faith craft and
I'm here testifying in support of SB 558
um so I am in a same-sex relationship my
wife and I just got married 6 months ago
and so we are starting the Journey of
Parenthood and so the comparison of
Parenthood for same-sex couple for women
versus heterosexual couple there's a lot
more Hoops to jump through a lot more
costs so right now because I am in a
place where I'm unemployed I could begin
this journey of wanting to become a
parent and know that I can take this
time off maybe incur the costs that come
with buying the sperm storing shipping
and then IUI or I could get a new job
and then hope that I can have that paid
parental leave to one become a parent
but even leading up to it taking all
this time off needed to uh have IUI for
the Journey of Parenthood as Katherine
mentioned IUI um it's recommended for
six Cycles with each cycle of IUI there
is a lot of appointments that come with
that because there's the pre-testing
there's um genetic testing to make sure
the sperm that you're using isn't going
to have um some genetic um issue um
making sure you're not a recessive
carrier for something there's blood
tests there's a lot of appointments
leading up to the point of IUI which
fine if that's not covered by insurance
but then IUI if you're doing six rounds
of it that's maybe 6 months if not
longer and so leading up to that you
need to uh purchase three to five vials
of sperm from a sperm bank and my wife
and I we've been looking at the cost
that can be upwards of $10,000 for the
sperm for the shipping for the storage
um just to get it to the doctor's office
so there are grants available to cover
that right now but a lot of them state
that you need to be someone with a prior
medical condition and it's not deemed
medically necessary for a same-sex
couple so my wife and I I would be the
one that would carry and we are in the
preconception part of getting ready for
Parenthood where we would meet with our
OBGYN and she has to do all this testing
to make sure that I am um in a good
place to potentially start the process
to become pregnant and a a heterosexual
couple they don't have to do all this
pre-testing or pay out of pocket for
sperm or anything and so we are looking
at incurring a very large um price to
become parent and it's not a guarantee
that I would get pregnant off of the
first vial of sperm um my wife and I
joined this queer conception group where
we've heard stories of um same-sex
couples it's taking them years to become
pregnant um so there's no guarantee that
off the first vial I would become
pregnant um if it's years of a process
that's a lot of money and also ensuring
with an employer if I am am trying to
become pregnant and it takes years to
become pregnant there's no guarantee
currently that the employer would allow
me to keep going to these appointments
to become a parent um so that's again
another hurdle to becoming a parent and
it's not fair there's another
restriction I guess to becoming a parent
and so for me I have ultimately wanted
to become a mom and I see all of my uh
heterosexual friends who are able to you
know they have sex great they become
pregnant um but the difference between
um IUI and IVF big difference um doctors
need to do this procedure because they
can track to make sure that um the sperm
is being properly placed in the uterus
um if you're doing this at home you're
not properly storing the sperm it could
go to waste you're wasting a ton of
money and so it's really important that
you have the medical necessity from a
doctor that states that you are able to
have the cost covered by insurance but
then also have them tracking the
procedures that are happening
so again it is very expensive and a
lengthy process and so for me to become
a mom this is very paral to me and I
would like to know that I don't have to
spend $10,000 plus whatever the cost of
all these medical appointments are going
to be um so again this is a medical
necessity for me as a same-sex uh couple
I know it's not for heterosexual couples
but being able to know that the
insurance will cover this and that we
don't have to um fight with insurance
carriers before we even get to these
appointments we want to know that we can
go to the appointment is going to be
covered and that we can hopefully become
a parent within the first couple rounds
instead of waiting um 12 months and then
potentially having to do IVF which then
even that's not covered by Insurance um
so I'm happy to answer any questions I
hope that covered it
representative
spear thank you I I missed something
that you said because uh I got something
a little confused so there's a lot of
stuff that goes on before you ever get
into the office to actually have the IUI
procedure M and you said that that could
cost as much as $10,000 yes so that but
that's not the question oh sorry yep and
that there are grants available to help
with that yes did I understand it
correctly that says those grants are
limited if you don't have insurance for
the IUI part of it or did I
misunderstand something no those grants
are limited to people that are already
deemed like infertile or you have
already a prior existing medical
condition it's not available for
same-sex couples that are just trying to
um become pregnant so you have to pay
the $10,000 equivalent already right and
that's not even the issue like whatever
we have to pay that but then on top of
of already paying $110,000 all those
medical appointments will add up really
yes okay thank you very much uh chair
hi chairman members of the committee my
name is Devin Quinn the director of
policy for the New Hampshire women's
Foundation I actually wanted to read a
letter um from an OBGYN who couldn't be
here today if you'll allow that um this
is from Dr Janet Perkins Howen uh dear
esteemed legislators I'm writing to urge
your support for the inclusion of
medical coverage for INT intrauterine
insemination for lesbian couples within
our state's Healthcare policies I also
write as an OBGYN who has spent her
entire career in the great state of New
Hampshire IUI is a vital assisted
reproductive technology that enables
many couples to conceive and start
families however despite its proven
Effectiveness and importance in
addressing infertility access to IUI
remains limited for lesbian couples this
lack of access poses Financial burdens
when seeking to build families once les
lesbian couples decide to start a family
IUI is phys physiologically necessary as
a first step every individual regardless
of sexual orientation should have access
to the medically necessary treatments
and services they need to start a family
furthermore endorsing the coverage of
IUI for lesbian couples aligns with our
state's values of fairness compassion
and support for families I urge your
consideration of this important issue
and to support legislative measures that
would clarify the medical necessity of
IUI for lesbian couples your endorsement
of this initiative would have a profound
and positive impact on the lives of many
individuals and families in our state
thank you um for your attention to this
matter Dr uh Janet Perkins
howand great thank you very much if
there if I may there was one question
you asked um about the coverage issue or
um the uh Municipal um impact um and I
just wanted to I guess sitting here are
you saying do we really need to make
sure that employers would let someone go
to a fertility treatment appointment and
you know that's actually why we have it
already in the books for for prenatal
appointments and you would might think
the same thing wouldn't everyone allow
people to attend prenatal appointments
but unfortunately we do have to have
that in statute for the very you know
small number of employee employers that
may not understand the importance of
that and so um it mimicking that
prenatal appointments is also really
important too and that's unpaid time um
it's and as you heard it's quick
appointments but maybe few appointments
maybe many appointments but they're
quick and so we just want to make sure
um especially if an employer doesn't
understand fertility treatments that
they understand that they do need to
make sure their employers can attend
those appointments if that
clarifies thank
you any other questions see none thank
you very much for your testimony chair
okay good afternoon good afternoon um my
name is Brianna HL and I am the legal
policy fellow at new Futures I'm my
testimony focuses on the second part of
the bill which is the workplace
protection uh especially for postpartum
care um currently the US is in a
maternal mortality crisis with a lot of
maternal deaths most mostly happening
around postpartum care so it's important
to have those workplace protections so
people can go to doctor's appointments
or and stay healthy without using all of
their paid time off and needing care and
I can answer any questions if there's
any what well because I know we have in
our statue that we want to protect
pregnant women it doesn't say how you
got pregnant there's no issue there so
I'm I'm I'm surprised talking about
postpartum because that's after the
baby's been born and that we give the F
we give you a woman right to stay home
and and that the we mandate the employer
can't fire you it's got to take you back
when you're done um postpartum death can
happen up to a year after the pregnancy
um and so that's more like more broader
so oh so you're adding to the the length
of time um no just for um postpartum
care in
great thank you any other questions from
the committee
members see none got one card left
Harrington yeah you already had to turn
it on it has to be
green good afternoon and thank you Mr
chairman we are here in support of
s558 my name is Lindsay Harrington this
is my wife Natalie we reside in
conquer a few months before we got
married in 2020 we began the truly
romantic task of deciding if it made
sense to be on the same insurance
policy working for larger nonprofits we
both had reasonably affordable premiums
the main difference was that Natalie had
in 2020 i' had been working for my
current employer for over 5 years and
knew my insurance premiums coverage and
deductibles were some of the best in the
state it's important to note that my
current organization is also has
generous parental leave and a
comprehensive integrated Equity
diversity inclusion and belonging
program surely my benefits would make
the most sense for us I did my due
diligence and met with my benefits
Department at work I shared the details
about Natalie's policy and the benefits
director and I agreed my organization's
policy likely made the most sense for
us I then got that pit in my stomach and
remembered to ask I just want to confirm
you're saying we my future wife and I we
are fully insured for fertility
treatment she nodded and said
emphatically yes Lindsay we are fully
insured in February 2021 we began our
family planning Journey a journey that
we quickly learned would be Qui very
costly for us after some initial tests
Natalie was ready to start II Cycles
when we talked to our financial
counselor at Boston ibf she told us our
insurance does not in fact cover IUI
treatment in cases where infertility has
not been
diagnosed and we would need to complete
12 Cycles unsuccessfully before
infertility coverage would kick
in the expected outof pocket cost would
be somewhere between 12,000 and 25,000
depending on our particular course of
treatment confused between what we had
originally been told by our insurance
and what we were being told by the
fertility clinic we contacted our close
friends who happened to work with
Lindsay they had the same insurance
plan and received treatment at the same
Fertility clinic with the same provider
our friend we asked our friends what her
and her husband had paid they were very
confused by our question but shared that
after 18 months of treatment they'd paid
maybe $200 in co-pays their treatment
was covered by Insurance well we would
have to bear the burden of all costs
associated with our treatments in March
of that year we contacted our
Reproductive Rights attorney kathern
Tucker Katherine helped us request to
write paperwork from the insurance
company and encouraged us to appeal this
decision through that appeal we were
provided with some additional relief the
number of out-of- pocket rounds was
reduced to six given that we are two
women in our 30s we made the decision to
move forward with treatment at that time
each round of IUI cost us out of pocket
$1,100 in addition to the cost of the
IUI we also had to cover other fees
associated with our treatment including
sperm medication and blood work we spent
$2,700 purchasing three vials of sperm
one of which will be stored for future
use adding additional cost of $3,100 for
storage not including the storage fees
we spent a total of
$5,199 before having a successful
pregnancy we have spent the past two
years discussing when we'd be ready to
start trying for a second child the
primary deciding factor on timing was
determining when we could balance the
financial burden of fertility treatment
a factor most couples don't have to
consider with each cycle we must examine
other areas of our life and determine
the priority balancing regular monthly
expenses extracurriculars for our son or
necessary Home Improvement projects
three months ago we started a new round
of IUI treatments and last week we had
our third cycle of treatments in hopes
of bringing a second child into our
family the cost of IUI treatment has
increased to
$1,650 so far we have spent almost $633
on medication $441 on blood work and
testing and
$2,415 on two additional vials of sperm
bringing us to a current running total
of
treatments our average total cost per
cycle of IUI increased 45% between 2021
and
2024 from
$250 to2
$957 if we end up needing to pay for six
cycles of IUI out of pocket this year we
will spend over $18,000 before our
insurance kicks
in we need to hear if a treatment was
successful is an extremely stressful
period for us this stress is compounded
as we are forced to look back at our
finances to determine when we can plan
for a fourth
round we know trying again right away
won't be an option for us as we have
spent almost $3,000 in the past three
months for each
treatment we will probably need to take
a few months off to save for additional
Cycles our question for the committee is
a simple one what is a family worth in
New
Hampshire for five cycles of IUI
treatment to build a family so far we
have SE spent $16
16,5
125 if we need to complete additional
the additional full six Cycles
IUI this round we will spend over
$26,000 building a
family is it worth it absolutely is it
fair and Equitable absolutely
not the fact is it costs more to be a
same-sex parent in New Hampshire than it
does to be a straight
parent we new
hampsh in New Hampshire currently leaves
it up to ures and companies to Define
what Equitable treatment actually looks
like we fully support the mod modern
economy act in the benefits it would
provide to families across New Hampshire
we appreciate the committee's
consideration of such an impactful
legislative
opportunity thank
spear the costs that you indicate or
costs that are similar to the costs that
out this bill this current bill is
covering a very small part of
that do you I I mean I is this going to
make any difference to you I mean it's
such a small part of the whole cost of
of IUI the whole package you know
getting the sperm and everything else it
would make a significant difference the
sperm alone cost so much money that
being able to offset any of that cost
with any of the treatment being covered
would allow us to immediately jump into
another cycle because we would be able
to personally we could afford this firm
right now we could not afford the
that thank you very much having no more
cards we will close the public hearing
on Senate Bill
and we will do the subcommittee next
Tuesday Health bills will do next
Tuesday
for
e